bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce ouh
là là faut que je me coupe le son là bas
salut à tous salut Laurent j'espère que
vous allez bien j'espère que tu es prêt
pour ce pour ce prochain match entre du
coup
les Shanghai Tigers et les Saint-Louis
ouais donc c'est le quatrième jour on
continue à découvrir les équipes
écoute ma foi hier on a on a regardé on
a vu Blitz Stream qui a emporté dans ce
match epic et contre une redoutable
équipe indienne donc très bon point pour
pour nos amis cannois et enfin Kanoa
au départ et après ça c'est ça s'est
étendu et ensuite on a vu un deuxième
match avec l'équipe de Nakamura qui
semble très fort même s'il Nakamura a
vécu une petite petite surprise à la
première partie quand Joséphine a une
Mann c'est la sensation certainement de
cette première ronde avec cette défaite
du carunakamura contre contre la jeune
joueuse allemande Joséphine
et donc voilà aujourd'hui on découvre
les deux dernières équipes donc des
Chinois contre des Américains on fait
vraiment
une revue de tous les effectifs ici et
voilà il y a des équipes qui ont été
très impressionnantes notamment la
n'était pas là le premier jour mais on a
vu une équipe indienne emmené par Vidy
très homogène ils ont pas joué le
dernier match c'est les seuls ils ont
gagné 8 et demi 3 et demi il y a pas eu
de dernier set donc c'était fini en
trois manches très très impressionnant
ou pas vraiment de grande star vous
dites bon c'est la limite mais
disons une équipe très très homogène et
très très dangereuse est-ce que ça
serait pas la clé dans un truc
c'est alors là tu m'as eu bravo alors on
va regarder c'est la première c'est ceux
qui sont là voilà c'est ouais
[Musique]
la la la la il y avait je sais pas c'est
dans celle-là je sais plus je sais plus
franchement j'ai obtenu que j'y
connaissais pas tellement pour être
honnête mais très très bon et évidemment
on a vu on a vu les chaises bras aussi
évidemment mené par les streamers
Canadiens à mené par Magnus Carlsen qui
a fait 4 sur 4 et qui a fait ils ont
fait Huit et demi donc il a marqué
la moitié des points tout simplement un
peu tout petit peu moins 0,25 de moins
que la moitié des points mais très
impressionnant le champion du monde ils
ont gagné aussi les norwenhums ont gagné
grâce à mausleep c'est la dernière
partie de kawaii bon bref il s'est passé
dans autre chose et aujourd'hui
mais ce qui est incroyable moi ce que je
trouve encore plus dingue
c'est qu'il abandonne pas ce que tu en
penses
t'abandonnes
j'ai trouvé ça incroyable de pas
abandonner mais j'ai abandonne tous les
jours je sais pas
avec une tour une tour de moins comme ça
avec deux pions c'est même pas tu as
même pas vu passer bon bref on va voir
en tout cas le score le choc du jour
Stéphane enfin le choc le premier choc
et un deuxième match à 19h qu'on
découvrira ensuite c'est comme tu l'as
dit les Saint Louis arche Bishop sera
évidemment le club de Saint-Louis qui ne
connaît pas le club de Saint-Louis avec
monsieur simcafield qui sponsorise
généreusement tout ça ces tournois
Saint-Louis la signe que Phil Cup
parfois d'autres tournois du random
chess du Kasparov du Magnus Carlsen un
scandale dont on a un peu entendu parler
voilà bon ça il peut rien il a plutôt
subi voilà mais en tout cas aux
États-Unis enfin c'est là c'est la
Mecque un petit peu de de détour à
l'échec ou voilà c'est la volonté de
[Musique]
d'un homme qui parle il parle très bien
français ça va être surpris quand
j'étais à la Saint Louis il est
complètement vilain
ouais c'est un peu étonnant mais voilà
il y a des gens comme ça qui apprennent
vite un peu tout
et sans aller c'est à dire qu'il a la
première fois qu'il était allé en France
c'était assez incroyable il parlait déjà
français c'est là qu'il avait appris
avec des cassettes quoi l'ancienne
il parle très bien donc on a les
Lignières Dominguez Benjamin BOC ni
Nicolas Théodore roux alors je sais pas
si tu les connais alors les nerf
Domingues qui ne connaît pas les liens
Dominguez très très grand joueur ma
génération exactement mon âge et
figure-toi Stéphane j'étais meilleur que
lui quand on était jeune
et bien il a été plus plus ténuant que
moi plus
il a été c'est vraiment un modèle tu
vois parce qu'il a force de il y a
toujours cru toujours accroché et petit
à petit c'était pas du tout un prodige
mais petit à petit ben voilà il a à 40
ans il a 2750 bon allez encore il a déjà
eu plus hein
chapeau à lui parce que c'est
c'est peut-être les cas les plus durs
quand tu es pas grand maître très jeune
en plus il était bon il est il est
cubain alors je sais pas qui était
vraiment sa vie s'il est vraiment et que
toute sa vie là-bas ou s'il est il est
venu aux États-Unis parce que maintenant
il habite aux États-Unis il a pas pu
jouer pendant 2 ans parce que il a
atteint de la green card et donc il y
avait aussi ce transfert fille à payer à
la fidélité donc il y a pas pu jouer
pendant deux ans mais il est revenu
après il a continué à travailler c'est
assez incroyable son histoire
Benjamin Buck d'origine hollandaise
enfin hollandais qui habite aux
États-Unis très bon joueurs très solide
on le connaît bien en Europe
Nicolas théodoru que je connais qu'on a
failli affronter lors de la dernière
ronde des Olympiades il joue pour les
Grecs il a fait une médaille d'or à son
échiquier et il a pas joué contre nous
il a eu peur il a eu peur
en fait ils avaient un choix cornélien
les Grecs soit ils assurer la médaille
d'or de Théodore en le mettant sur le
banc soit il tentait leur chance pour
nous battre et faire un top 10 bon ils
ont pas fait jouer tout de rousse qui
est un peu étrange bon finalement mais
voilà donc théodoru un jeune un jeune
qui monte Alice lit que je connais pas
je sais pas si tu veux plus j'ai déjà vu
son nom quelque part dans les
championnats américains mais
je sais pas du tout
quel âge elle a d'ailleurs c'est assez
bizarre de voir
de voir FM alors c'est une fille tu as
déjà vu ce genre de choses
normalement c'est WFM et je sais qu'il y
a plus
j'avais plusieurs filles qui sont
titrées qui ont quitte masculin donc
petite masculin de mi c'est normal j'ai
aussi mais FM je l'avais pas vu ouais
moi non plus ouais
italienne
la soeur d'un grand maître italien
d'ailleurs comment il s'appelle c'est
Bruno elle est maître fille aussi
et donc en face on a veilli bon très
connu jeune prodige qui a eu du mal à
percer dans le top 10 mondial mais quand
même 2722 ensuite la champion du monde
entier Juventus très très forte
évidemment
Souilly qu'on connaît qu'on va essayer
de bien prononcer ça serait déjà pas mal
à défaut de le connaître et ensuite Lou
yping et il est 16h31 ça ne devrait pas
tarder à à commencer Stéphane je vais me
mettre tout de suite on va se mettre en
position et essayer de voir tout ça
alors
ça a pas commencé chez toi on va voir on
va voir les caméras alors est-ce que les
caméras on espère voilà on voit les nerf
Dominguez est-ce que est-ce que les nerf
il a les blancs aujourd'hui ou pas
légèrement décalé tiens
[Musique]
non en fait il faut juste que tu que tu
mettes je pense clique sur une partie
aussi c'est ce qui va faire en fait ce
qu'on voit un petit peu les pions c'est
au dessus et on va voir son temps et
tout donc je clique sur une partie mais
j'avais peur de rater le début des
autres donc sur ta sur ta
comment c'est du coup la partie entre
nous hipping et Dominguez donc
évidemment
avec le 3 6 on va voir sûrement un fou
prends C4 arrivée et probablement
derrière il y a du C5
donc je connais pas trop cette position
mais j'imagine que ça m'empêcher
ma dernière partie en Bundesliga il y a
une semaine avec les Blancs donc faut
deux il m'a joué alors je pensais le
surprendre et du coup j'ai été très reçu
j'ai été très reçu il m'a joué cahier
BD7 je savais que c'était le c'est le
coup qui m'embêtait le plus pour pour
être très honnête
il y a longtemps et que à mon grand
désarroi d'ingeren a joué un match de
speechs j'étais liquéfié devant le match
je comme je commentaire direct
j'essayais de garder quand même
ma Poker Face mais alors c'était
incroyable donc il montre cette idée
avec l'idée B6 cavalier 5 et en fait tu
veux faire fu F3 assez vite ok c'est
intéressant si les Noirs connaissent pas
voilà parce que tu tu vois faut baisser
tout froid tu poses quand même des
questions c'est pas très agréable mais
en fait c'est une reconnaisse il y a pas
grand chose et donc faut deux pions
c'était contre contre Sarine non contre
Ariane ok ok
j'ai gagné quand même mais c'était
vraiment pas grâce à l'ouverture et donc
parce qu'il est sur B3 il m'a fait
baisser ça tempo là je me suis c'est pas
possible qu'est-ce que comment c'est
possible d'être aussi pour ça et là et
là je considérais en fait j'avais
regardé un petit peu cette position je
considérais qu'après il faut F3 tu vois
toujours en a parlé hier de ce problème
du Fou du Fou des 7
kd2k et C6 ouais j'aurais plutôt fait un
coup de fouf 3 un moment un peu plus tôt
tu vois pour
typiquement ici par exemple ben voilà tu
fais que c'est 6 mais tu as une petite
alors c'est pas un drame mais
petit avantage pour les blancs tu peux
prétendre à quelque chose voilà
je vais essayer pendant ce temps j'étais
très très
intéressé par le début de partie mais je
vais essayer de mettre notre ami
Louis ping est-ce que alors le problème
des joueurs chinois c'est que je les
connaissais
hein je vais noter
le 4 s'éveille ouais non c'est quasiment
sûr le 4 c'est
une chance sur deux je crois le 3 c'est
c'est Juven jaune alors ça c'est c'est
un peu du monde champion du monde
arbitre très très fort joueuse
très très fort joueuse là de donc elle
va être là-bas alors du coup je vais
faire
en mode est-ce que c'est lui ou pas
c'est ça c'est ça la grande question
c'est est-ce que ça va être lui ou pas
pour celui qui a été joué du coup
Gmail
le 2 alors est-ce que c'est lui
sur internet je viens je sais pas du
tout qui c'est un jeu on s'en excuse
évidemment on les connaît pas les
joueurs donc là c'est embêtant
c'est très très gênant comme moment mais
voilà a priori
c'est pas lui
je crois que c'est lui ouais mais je
suis pas sûr à 100% tu sais on n'est
jamais vraiment sûr
mais il a l'air d'avoir je crois que
c'est lui tu crois que c'est lui bon ben
écoutez
je vais voir si bon voilà on se met pas
de régie en panique là c'est quand même
pas mal là on s'en sort pas mal salut à
tous évidemment je me suis trompé je
crois que lui c'est pas en fait on
dirait qu'ils sont jumeaux je crois que
lui c'est
il me semble
et on va pas bien s'entendre si tu viens
de me de mettre un erreur
en vrai c'est pas si clair et l'autre
c'est fait voir
mais par rapport aux lunettes
bon on va dire c'est mieux non non mais
je pense que ouais je pense que lui
c'est ça va être Louis
regardez-moi ça on essaye Louis pink
c'est marqué Louis ping donc en fait
loup
et souvent on est vraiment désolé on
s'en excuse auprès de nos amis donc
ils étaient pas c'est pas eux hein au
Championnat du Monde par équipe
peut-être qu'avec souris quand même
alors pour les pour les amateurs de
sensations pas forte c'est ça c'est ça
le coup faut prendre F6 dans prime F6 et
là le rêve c'est de ramener ce cavalier
en Détroit la fameuse le fameux cavalier
ou le fenderson qui viennent des finales
comme ça mais bon c'est vrai que les
noirs sont assez actifs là pour imaginer
qu'il est BD de Tours FC 8 kd3 quelque
chose comme ça et c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué de tant qu'il reste des tours
c'est toujours très compliqué un
problème
il a pas du tout fait ça et il est plus
ambitieux parce que ça c'est vrai qu'il
faut prendre un M6 assurer
assurer au moins la nul clairement
on ne peut plus logique Stéphane
c'est pas très agréable pour les Noirs
je sais pas ce que tu en penses
aussi tant que dame la tour en prison
donc en fait il y a un vis-à-vis de
cloué la tour emprise
c'est un jeu plus agréable t'as pas trop
de risques en fait avec les Blancs et
mais bon si demain arrive à bien se
coordonner et à bien mettre leur plan en
place a priori la qualité sera proche
mais bon il faut déjà trouver quelque
chose d'intéressant à faire je trouve
que c'est une grande force de dominer
notamment contre ce genre de joueur
moins bien classé tu vois il a quand
même 2500 en 2007 il s'enflamme pas il
joue tranquille il joue normal alors que
tu aurais plutôt tendance à jouer
quelque chose de plus agressif il
s'enflamme pas Dominguez jamais et ça
c'est c'est une grande force même si il
perd une partie il va pas il va pas
s'énerver
calme assez assez impressionnant
Dominguez on va on va faire un petit
tour un petit tour des stades
donc il y a les Noirs contre Souilly du
coup ça doit être ça doit être le 2 sur
c'est pas trompé voilà
et Benjamin Bocq on va on va le chercher
maintenant
c'est un peu ça le truc et Benjamin BOC
il est là il a les Noirs
salut à tous
je m'enflamme plus souvent que ce que tu
pourrais penser
alors
on a une italienne là non plus ça
s'enflamme pas ça joue architecte
avec est-ce qu'on met le pion A4 vous
voyez il a joué à 6 à 5 ici c'était une
chose à l'époque Vichy à Nantes m'a joué
m'a joué comme ça aussi ce à 5
exactement ici qui est intéressant donc
il veut menacer clairement qui empêche
B4 et qui aussi sur fubé 5 maintenant on
aura cavalier à 7 comme on l'a vu dans
la partie il faut aussi voilà propose un
échange et maintenant on fait cavalier à
7 prendre message
à 5 mais en fait on a aussi gagné un
temps en étant pas obligé de jouer fou à
7 donc finalement ça se ça s'équilibre
et c'est pas c'est pas ridicule cette
histoire de assise d'abord et un sac à
donc là on mange bien de la part de fou
si on fait ça on ferait en fait c'est
quoi aux gens
les Noirs ont la terre de fou et les
Blancs n'ont pas donc du coup la
pollution est très très bonne pour pour
les blancs donc important essayer quand
la position souffre surtout de
d'échanger des fous enfin de si vous
perdez un de vos fous et essaie de
manger sur l'adversaire tant qu'à faire
et donc là d'être des procès 5 qui était
très logique et ici les noirs sont très
bien
on peut pas dire qu'il soit très mal
après ça
c'est important de garder les fous quoi
[Musique]
les noirs sont bien sortis je vois pas
de raison de considérer que les blancs
et obtenu un quelconque avantage
d'ouverture
je vois pas très bien j'ai l'impression
qu'on va jouer des coups normaux comme
kssis
et voilà on peut ouais tour des 8 par
exemple sur KSI k j'ai l'impression
qu'on aura toujours la même C5 qui est
quand même gênant pour les pour les
blancs
bon on va voir ce qui va se passer mais
clairement une ouverture réussie de la
part de Benyamin BOC et si on allait
voir ah ça c'est ça c'est la très très
belle appariement avec todoro Nicolas
contre Juventus il a joué de manière
très agressive je vais essayer de les
trouver
d'ailleurs un joueur qui a pas longtemps
il me semble
ouais ouais mais alors il est en pleine
il
avait quasiment 2006 déjà il était pas
encore quand même un petit peu le le la
vitesse à laquelle il progresse tu vois
clairement
faire la 2500 et l'autre et donc lui il
est tellement monté vite en fait que
2006 tu es pas encore grand maître et
Théodore ouais je l'ai c'est un très
très bon genre aussi Internet
attendez je vais vous montrer la
position et là on a une pagaille une
pagaille assez absolue
alors là c'est assez chaud une catalane
on avait un
buggé non
Florian Philippot non c'était pas lui
qui avait un genre allemand qui
s'appelle comme ça ou je me suis plus
Florian Philippot c'est quelqu'un
d'autre
non c'était pas ça ressemblait mais
c'était Philippe Philippe quelque chose
et tu l'as transformé en
désolé désolé
[Musique]
[Rires]
t'inquiète pas on peut tu peux dire une
vacherie il a pas trop de en général aux
élections il fait pas il fait pas des
scores
tu vois
les petits scores en fait faut se moquer
faut se moquer des gens qui font des
petits scores sinon on est alors je vais
essayer de trouver
aussi il est où Théodore
alors donc là on voit déjà la caméra
vous aviez
ça joue en jaune qui est championne du
monde c'est pas la numéro 1 chinoise
mais à chaque fois du monde en Chine les
échecs c'est chez les filles c'est
monstrueux bon chez les hommes aussi
mais chez les filles c'est monstrueux au
niveau ça joue à médaille olympique la
médaille d'or olympique si ça la gagne
pas en gros il y avait
pas mais c'est vrai que les dernières
Olympiades alors pas les dernières parce
que là du coup la Chine est et la Russie
donc pas participer
mais
avant c'était les sur les quatre cinq
dernières Olympiades un mano Amano entre
l'équipe l'équipe de Chine et de Russie
chez chez d'un compétition
des dames donc des des joueuses donc
clairement ouais deux nations qui
dominent très très largement les échecs
féminins avec avec les chinoises qui se
permettent le luxe
de le même paramètres parce que là elles
ont elles ont joué le jaune elles ont
bien sûr oui fans qui ne jouent même
plus enfin qui joue même plus trop qui
est la numéro 1 qui a 26 50
et
on a aussi alors je sais plus le nom
mais une qui s'est qualifié pour les
candidat enfin pour la candidate et la
Chine franchement c'est c'est une nation
qui est juste
hyper impressionnante F5 a été joué
souvent c'est un coup important ici en
cette position qui évite un petit peu
enfin c'est une réaction un peu dire
pour éviter les pièces blanches qui
arrivent trop vite mais de l'autre côté
F5 ça fait quand même pas mal à la
position que le pion aussi derrière la
structure j'ai pu en E6 C4 C6 C6 et A4
c'est vraiment c'est pas que mal là
d'avoir une structure bon tu as des
pions tu as des pions en plus mais
[Musique]
structure
c'est ça une structure en carton
donc on va voir ce qui fait en tout cas
théodoro il joue de manière très très
agressif ce début cette catalane qui en
envoie beaucoup de Catalans en ce moment
c'est pas que la Catalane soit vraiment
une ouverture sur la réfutation de ça
mais on a trop de mal sur cahier C3
genre témoigne il y a tellement
d'options ici c'est la position
principale entre guillemets il y a ces 5
et très fort la semi-tarache qui pose
beaucoup de problèmes fubéca taragosine
et carvida qui est pas qui est pas tout
de suite réfuté on peut aussi jouer une
Merrant on peut aussi jouer des Vienna
bref il y a énormément d'options est-ce
qu'il fait que les joueurs de D4 avec
les blancs ils disent mais finalement un
catalan pourquoi pas
remis au goût du jour c'est un étang
et donc
on a toujours un jeu actif toujours des
peut toujours sacrifier les pions comme
il a fait ici et pour avoir du jeu alors
qui est mieux
c'est très très dur à dire
mais en tout cas ça joue clairement
c'est c'est quelque chose
pour attaquer
à 5 qui viennent jouer pour jouer à 6 en
imagine avec un filet sur la Tour Eiffel
[Musique]
et donc là il va falloir bouger une ou
deux pièces priori
il faut pas se laisser enfiler comme ça
donc soit tu bouges la tour
est-ce qu'on a des facteurs explicatifs
de cette percée chinoise côté échec
notamment et chaque féminin alors déjà
il y a dingueren qui représente quand
même les échecs masculin mais c'est vrai
que c'est moins flagrant qui a peut-être
un champion du monde c'est moins
flagrant à mon avis de ce que j'ai vu
c'est tout simplement qu'ils ont
ils ont beaucoup de Grand Maître
entraîneurs coach voilà comme des
joueurs qui sont dans cette équipe qui à
mon avis coach
coach et les chinoise et donc du coup
voilà et c'est plus compliqué encore
mais ça ça va venir c'est la deuxième
génération à mon avis c'est les VI les
dignes qui pourront coacher finalement
les futurs champions de demain et voilà
donc ça se forme petit à petit et c'est
vrai que c'est plus simple entre
guillemets dans les échecs féminins
parce que finalement ils ont déjà cette
génération notamment
le plus connu qui est y est yéchange qui
a formé toute cette toute cette
génération alors lui ça fait 30 ans
qu'il est grand maître donc c'est lui
qui a qui a vraiment été le fer de lance
et ensuite petit à petit effet boule de
neige tout le monde a été formé et je
pense que dans 10-15 ans les chinois ils
seront ils ont des nouvelles des
nouveaux champions parce que leur
système de détection est très au point
et ils ont des vies des dings qui feront
les coachs et là et là ça sera pas mal
effectivement d'ailleurs Wendy qui joue
le tournoi qui qui est numéro 1 de ce
type là vous voyez qui avait été je
crois 2700 hello à 16 ans
il avait une courbe à la à la carcène
du monde il avait sorti il avait sorti
qu'il avait sorti il avait sorti
tellement mieux c'est pour ça que j'en
parle tu vois il avait à 16 ans il avait
2700 ouais 10 quoi à peu près et
maintenant il a quel âge non
23 ans non il a le même élo il y a pas
percé
donc c'est pas parce que tu es très très
fort très jeune après il y a plein de
tests à chaque il y a plein de paliers
et
c'est la folie et ouais non bien sûr
bien sûr c'est très compliqué de savoir
c'est pour ça que tous ces jeunes par
exemple ces jeunes Indiens qui
deviennent grands pas tous au top 10
mondial c'est pas possible au bout d'un
moment il y a pas assez de place pour
tout le monde donc on va voir après les
il y a tellement de choses qui qui sont
qui viennent en compte
et donc notamment
ce truc il y a des déceptions dans une
cave de chaleur plus ou moins mais il y
a forcément des déception c'est toujours
c'est toujours compliqué de gérer tout
ça le stress le sommeil pendant les
tournois il y a tellement de facteurs
qui font pour devenir un top top que
c'est c'est compliqué parce que là là
quand même bon tu as besoin qui qui
n'est plus à présenter je pense
maintenant tu as aussi les Indiens ta
Prague tu as goûté
l'allemand enfin tu as quand même pas
mal de monde qui qui arrive qui rend
très très fort et très très prometteur
mais au final
parce que c'est la preuve que que c'est
pas si simple à 16 ans il avait 2720
et ils ont même âge à peu près que
avaient waidi donc on sait pas encore il
y a beaucoup de choses à faire c'est
même à lire ça
il est hyper fort mais bon
puisque ça mais bon on sait pas encore
hein ce que ce que les ce que l'avenir
nous réserve est-ce que les gens vont
faire bien sûr c'est dur de savoir qui
sera le après donc il y aura un nouveau
champion du monde mais dans dans 5-10
ans c'est très dur à dire alors moi je
pensais mais c'est vrai et à chaque
tournoi je change un peu d'avis c'est
l'opportuniste dans un superbe ce qui a
gagné il m'a déçu quand même avec c'est
tellement spécial
ça fait un moment déjà depuis je pense
depuis le Championnat du Monde bah de
rapide avec cette révélation bon c'est
du rapide bien sûr mais en fait
exploitent
d'accord après il a fait le chocolat du
monde ou la rasé tout le tournoi juste
après arrivé en demi-finale et perdre
contre je crois que c'était contre la
carte
et
là encore une fois au stade style enfin
franchement il est il est il est hyper
motivé il travaille beaucoup et puis
même pratiquement physiquement il a
l'air dans les tournois j'ai vu aux
Olympiades il y a pas un sourire pas un
truc
il a l'air il fait beaucoup penser il
est très comparé d'ailleurs il est très
comparé casse pas enfin dans l'attitude
notamment dans ce travail systématique
ce sérieux voilà il est il est très très
comparé à kasparante donc bon on lui
souhaite la même carrière ça sera pas
forcément évident mais en tout cas c'est
vrai qu'il est il est il est
impressionnant à d'où ça tombe après on
verra des jeunes Indiens vous cachez le
plus jeune de cette génération
clairement il a il a 16 ans donc
peut-être aussi ouais le bah c'est ça je
te flagrant nos rage vous cacher
peut-être de plus jeune un tiens le plus
solide effectivement alors faut être
cinq revenons à quand même aux parties
on discutera tout mais peut-être dites
nous hein dans le dans le dans le chat
qui est préféré qui est votre favori
alors E5 qu'est-ce qui se passe Stéphane
si on prend c'est quoi la combine et en
fait ça alors une pièce non
c'est ça donc ça ça va pas c'est plus en
prison donc E5 malin de la part de
Juventus par contre il y a eu deux nuls
entre Souilly et donc de nulle signé
vous les avez là les résultats et en bas
vous avez le score du du match donc en
bas de nous vous avez les résultats en
live du minimat des quatre parties et
tout en bas du stream à côté de
l'écusson enfin du logo de chaise.com
vous avez le score global du match qui
est évidemment pour l'instant comme
c'est le premier match bon mais c'est le
même score que dans le minimal mais ça
va changer il reste une autre partie
reste partie reste aussi vaillis contre
Alice
sinon parce que tu vois que comme une
Guez qui est le numéro 1 et ben arrêtez
en échec par le numéro 4 chinois et du
coup maintenant ben
Alice Lee donc 1284 je crois exactement
et tu vois ben au final bah je retrouve
il y en a un problème de retransmission
on va changer de
on a un problème là parce que là ça
s'est arrêté il y a marqué 00 pour
veiller donc on va aller sur la partie
qui marche on vous tient au courant et
oui non mais les Chinois moi je te l'ai
dit hein tu étais là oui ils ont l'air
fort les Américains moi je j'ai parlé
sur un chinois me prends pas mon pareil
hein tu savais même pas qui jouer encore
justement mais j'ai pas plus d'infos
aujourd'hui mais je t'assure ils sont
tous bons
le fait d'avoir une féminine à 25 50 ça
calme parce qu'en plus par rapport à la
moyenne et l'eau
ben je vous rappelle que les féminines
qui ont plus de 23,50 et Ben sont en
fait
remis à 23,50 donc jouer une Jul elle
compte comme une donc 230 plus quand
même intéressant comme comme un peu
Magnus Magnus et même pas 200 points de
plus c'est 150 60
mais du coup ça te permet de d'avoir un
dernier chéquier très solide parce que
généralement quand tu mets bon ça c'est
plus difficile on va dire d'avoir une
féminine à 2006-2007 il n'a pas donc
donc du coup avoir une féminine à 2550
c'est quand même c'est c'est un avantage
assez énorme mais là en l'occurrence tu
l'as bien tu vas bien pointé parce
qu'elle prend l'eau là il va falloir
qu'elle se calme sur le rythme des pions
parce que ça fait ça fait depuis en deux
coups ça continue comme ça il va plus
rester beaucoup dans quelques temps en
plus le problème c'est qu'on attaque la
tour intermédiaire on avait le cavalier
en prise mais regardez sur Tours C8 sur
ici attaquer deux pièces il y a ce
cavalier au sein qui est très très fort
qui protège ici qui attaque ici qui
permet de se recycler ensuite donc elle
joue tomber 8 je vous joins le jour mais
maintenant E4 fois 6 et ça sent bon pour
l'équipe de Saint-Louis là avec deux
pions passés liés en plus globalement
ça fait un peu ça fait peur on peut soit
encaisser soit poussé on sait pas
mais
[Musique]
je sais pas je sais pas moi je serais
hyper tenté de prendre en fait parce que
fou ces quatre pour déstabiliser mon
cavalier j'ai l'impression que j'ai
quand même une belle fourchette là
donc on peut faire ça au minimum sachant
que des 5 est quand même un coup mais
donner case noir comme ça j'aime pas
trop mais bon on va voir ce qu'il va
faire KF4 ça a l'air pas mal il faut
mettre
très concret ah non pardon c'est quoi
les cours il a joué quoi il a joué F4
et là il réfléchit
bon écoute pourquoi pas peut-être
pousser alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait maintenant
il a joué des 5 bon mais il y a pas une
grosse différence entre des 5 et aussi
va être prochainement jouer peut-être
d'ailleurs tout de suite
je pensais
mais j'ai l'impression qu'on donne des
petites chances quand même pratique
alors je parle pas de
je sais pas avec un fou comme ça je sais
pas j'aime pas trop bon il a pris ici on
reprend
[Musique]
du coup mais bon effectivement tu as
raison on navigue tranquillement
alors rêve de jouer d'ailleurs Tour
Eiffel 3 et menace 7 euros qui est pas
content
je l'ai vu faire non de la tête
pourquoi il fait dans la tête
de cette tour de 4 secondes il se
préfère pète
il y a pas moyen de me couvrir et non
c'est énorme
attends on va voir la fin de la partie
priorité au direct il a fait nul alors
qu'il est gagnant attends je vérifie
avec les variantes il est gagnant il est
gagnant
il a commencé à
psychoter un peu là tu vois tours et tu
t'en vas alors pour CE4
échecs
avec ton avec le mat du couloir mais tu
reviens en bon ben tu vas faire ça bon
effectivement c'est pas
fou derrière et ça ira quoi ouh là là il
est en dépression là bah il peut parce
que là ça coûte cher et on a veilli
contre Alice à l'Isly
on va essayer de trouver enfin je vais
essayer de trouver leur caméra avec un
peu de chance
incroyable sauvetage en tout cas de de
champion du monde j'ouvre une journée
les siècles avec un
fausse perpète au centre de l'échiquier
mais tu vois ça c'est aussi à cause du
du temps qui avait théodoro à la pendule
avec 4 secondes à la pendule 4 secondes
il a pas eu le temps de
prendre le risque aussi de mettre son
roi en B1 alors de rage de rage je le
fais tu sais en fait c'est des trucs je
peux la perdre même tu vois en fait
c'est un moment où je suis prêt à perdre
moi ça va être plein de fois de
tellement poussé que tu sais que tu
joues pour la paix en France
qu'il a et tu vois il s'est il s'est
repris pour ne pas
attendri il est parti il a gagné un pays
donc on va voir peut-être rapidement
cette partie
et voilà un début bon ben voilà un début
d'un joueur à 2007 contre une joueuse à
2003 ou il cherche un déséquilibre quoi
qu'il arrive alors c'est pas très bon
mais ça déséquilibre la position
et en plus c'est pas très bon mais c'est
raisonnable c'est pas non plus un
désastre pour les noirs
donc on voit la typique attaque à stanle
moi ce qu'on m'a appris en fait je sais
pas si on l'a appris aussi je l'ai
compris
à travers l'expérience mais sans le foot
casse blanche c'est galère pour mater
dans les stagnante parce que tu as du
mal à organiser G4 et
je sais pas comment comment on fait pour
mater elle a fait ben prend celle-ci ça
c'est un coup j'aime pas du tout parce
que ça ça donne du contre-jour je sais
pas j'aurais j'aurais essayé de faire
autre chose parce que là le contre jeu
des Noirs il arrive pas
et là maintenant ouais voilà c'est ça
elle s'est fait avoir sur les dames là
où elle a ouvert elle-même c'est dommage
ça c'est un petit manque
d'expérience là voilà elle a ouvert
cette colonne c'est ce qu'il a perdu
lié à Alicia qui a l'air sur moi j'ai la
photo j'ai la photo je vais essayer de
la trouver
à l'issy c'est la 5 on va essayer de la
trouver pour vous la montrer si elle est
toujours là voilà il est là ouais elle
est jeune clairement
mais
et quoi que en plus c'était pas clair
maintenant il a eu du mal
c'est vrai
il faut des 5 apparemment la gaffe
qu'est-ce qu'il fallait faire il fallait
jouer dame C8 d'après l'ordinateur ça
c'est pas ça
me plait
je sais pas je vais regarder
on joue on est joueur
mais ok
difficile apparemment c'est pas le coup
hyper intuitif
qui pourrait être sympa
vu que tu me dis que c'est un coup un
peu bizarre
en fait
comment je passe
ok bon premier coup elle a quand même
assez tentant tac ton ton fou je me
place des trois quand même
[Musique]
ça a du sens aussi ça empêche ça empêche
pousser quatre allez on va dire cavalier
à 5 mais non si vous trouvez un truc ok
c'est pas ça
peut être une idée
moi il y a du V3 qui peut qui peut
arriver le 5 ah c'est intéressant bluff
c'est quoi non il a proposé
ou pas c'est ton troisième essai ou pas
attends attends attends
en vrai c'est pas mal mais
quoi
je te fais confiance ça va être
intéressant
c'est quand même aussi une idée
[Musique]
sans rapidement et après
du coup
tu vas comprendre pourquoi
j'ai 7 même idée mais voilà faut F6 bon
écoute me demande pas pourquoi parce que
pour mettre le cavalier en 5 alors je
suppose que tu sais mieux que fouger 7
parce qu'en fait tu as pas avoir peur tu
contrôle bien les cases noires pourquoi
tu sais c'est mystérieux ce jeu donc
vous dessin cavaliers 7
dans mes fluide fou G7 Damas 8 et là il
a poussé son pion bon il a eu à il a eu
à l'expérience quand même pays
clairement il a poussé les pions là et
ok ah ben une victoire pour pour nos
amis chinois dans ce premier
match enfin premier mini match
et pendant que je règle tout ça on va
avoir la deuxième ronde
et donc l'élément qui va commencer par
quelques dans quelques instants
normalement là
je regarde de toute façon je suis en
plein dans mes réglages
et du coup alors pour la ronde de
l'appareil man je voulais les donner ta
branche tu les donne ou tu la regardes
tout seul en fait ouais non j'aimerais
tout seul c'est bon
donc pour le pour le chat on va voir du
coup avec les Blancs
Dominguez contre Gucci
donc voilà ça c'est première appariement
ensuite avec les Blancs encore donc on
aura Benjamin BOC contre l'eau hipping
et ensuite on aura walili de voir à
l'instant là avec les Blancs contre
Nicolas Théodore
et
ensuite dernière table le match des
féminines avec Johan Jones contre Alice
ça arrive à la honte de 1 parce que
d'habitude c'est vrai qu'on a pas
habitué à ce que justement les joueuses
sur les moins bien classés mais là pas
du tout on a la champion du monde
aujourd'hui donc ça marche pas comme ça
on va regarder
[Musique]
entre les
Américains c'était de mémoire Robson et
le format on le rappelle le format le
format cadence 10 + 2 les compositions
en équipe ne dépasse pas 2551 chaque
jour affronte tous les joueurs d'équipe
adversement total de 4 ans de chacun
chaque joueur ailleurs deux bords de
noir la première équipe à 8 et demi
remporte le match en cas d'égalité les
départages détermine l'équipe gagnante
et comment ça marche c'est taiborak et
bien voilà les mecs de la ronde 4
couleurs inversée cadence 3 + 2 en cas
de nouveau match nul on va jusqu'au bout
de la nuit en e+2 tant qu'à deux partout
ça joue des canards cadeaux et demi
c'est terminé
on va voir tout ça tu me dis quand ça
commence pendant ce temps je vais je
vais continuer mes petits
l'âge de Alice lie parce qu'on m'a
demandé et en fait elle a 14 ans elle a
14 ans et ouais incroyable on est en
2009 elle est maître international
féminin 2320 et l'eau
donc 14 ans intéressant ah ouais ouais
pas mal
ça c'est sûr
c'est sûr c'est sûr donc VI à cette fois
les blancs si je me si je ne m'abuse
on est d'accord sur cette info
[Musique]
oui contre Nicolas tour de roue et
ensuite tu auras
joues avec les Blancs contre Alice lit
ça n'a pas encore commencé on voit les
joueurs qui commencent un peu à
s'installer
donc apparemment intéressant on voit
encore déjà la queue les Chinois le
Shanghai Tiger et ben il mène un petit
point
donc par rapport
ouais en fait je pense que les Chinois
vraiment ils essayent vraiment de de
neutraliser
les normes Dominguez devant c'est
vraiment le plus fort de l'équipe
clairement
ils sont pas mal ils sont pas mal
notamment à chaque fois qu'on entre
Alice League et bon c'est très forte
joueuse mais elle est quand même censée
être moins forte que que tous les GM
chinois qu'elle va rencontrer donc
du coup du coup c'est
c'est un point potentiel qui peuvent
avoir à chaque ronde après je dis ça
mais bon
ça un petit peu hier quand on a vu
Joséphine aindman qui qui a battu ma
caméra et qui a dit tête plutôt la règle
malheureusement le vélo il fait pour
beaucoup donc Souilly
2 d'accord donc ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va repasser comme ça sous vos yeux
ébahis vous allez
vous allez voir apparaître les Lignières
Dominguez et peut-être sous au bon
endroit
ce que d'ailleurs
c'était pas contre lui qu'il avait je
crois que c'était lui non qui avait
gagné une partie
c'était contre qui qu'il avait gagné une
partie en avec les blancs sur une une
pétrole en moins de 10 coups
c'était ouais ouais contre Mourad
diabadi
Mora diabadi c'était au championnat
ça fait rire que de revoir
Dominguez jouer une défense russe avec
les Blancs donc après ok donc c'est
contre on avait dit le nom
et tu vas voir l'image dans quelques
instants
techniques et bon qui fait ce qu'elle
peut ça change de couleur ils ont un
mauvais idée donc une petite pétrole
exacte et Dominguez grand amateur de
Petrov avec les noirs
nous sommes quelle ronde et bien très
bonne question c'est la c'est la
première ronde et on découvre les on a
vu déjà il y a 16 équipes 8 matchs et on
découvre le 7e match donc chaque équipe
aura joué un match chacun ce soir des
matchs toutes les semaines avec des
éliminations au fur et à mesure et
ensuite c'est la grande fête c'est les
quarts de finale avec les 8 meilleurs
équipes des matchs élimination direct
donc là c'est un petit un petit galop
Tigo d'échauffement mais faut pas se
claquer à l'échauffement c'est ça le
truc on peut se faire sortir aussi assez
rapidement donc
situation difficile
et comme c'est un système suisse où
quand on gagne on joue l'équipe qui a
gagné quand on perd on joue une équipe
qui a perdu mais comme c'est très
homogène bah c'est pas vraiment une
bonne affaire de de c'est jamais une
bonne affaire de perdre mais là c'est
pas du tout sûr de gagner le prochain
match c'est ça le truc
quand tu vois juste le match hier de
Blitz entre contre les Indiens et bah tu
vois que c'était vraiment quasiment pile
ou face au final c'est vraiment des
équipes qui étaient aussi forte que
l'autre et au final cette équipe de
Kevin Bordy qui est passé à victorieuse
dans ce match mais c'est vrai que ça
aurait très bien pu être l'inverse ça se
joue à rien tout à fait donc c'est c'est
ultra choix c'est ultra chaud et
alors dans cette partie Dame des 7
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait jouer ici
donc c'est une position qui est quand
même assez symétrique
Dame des 7 ouais faut absolument essayer
d'occuper la colonie ou de faire en
sorte qu'il se passe quelque chose au
niveau du du dynamisme pour les pour les
blancs parce que là ça peut s'égaliser
très très vite Dominique regardez il
prend son temps maintenant parce qu'il
sait très bien que s'il trouve pas un
truc
tout de suite ça va être
ça va être compliqué de faire en sorte
qu'il se crée quelque chose
ou là qu'est-ce que j'ai fait là par
exemple
un tour au dos par exemple qui a l'air
bon normal on va doubler les tours 8
sûrement et les Noirs veulent juste
changer les pièces MG3 tu vas faire quel
F5
qui va arriver
et ce que je fais un truc comme même
cavalier 3 il y a peut-être du dmg4 qui
peut arriver avec un
des pièces
parfois
on a des plans avec B3 C4 aussi pour
essayer de déstabiliser à tout prix
vraiment les les Noirs ce qui est pas
évident dans cette ligne un peu appelé
la Varane chinoise d'ailleurs ce fouet 5
roquefou 7 c'est joué par énormément de
chinois ça a été repris par Yann
Christophe Douda le joueur le très très
fort joueur le numéro 1 pour le nez tout
simplement donc ça une variante très
populaire très très solide tandis que la
variante fun c'est plutôt fous des 6 qui
a été joué par notamment récemment par
Yann et pomyachi au championnat du monde
face à face à Magnus Carlsen une varante
qui peut se compliquer très vite tandis
que faux F5 fois 7 c'est souvent un
légère avantage pour les blancs tu vois
il joue cavalier 3 et sur du long terme
alors on essaie de faire en sorte
[Musique]
d'obtenir un petit plus mais c'est pas
évident alors est-ce que qu'est-ce qui
se passe sur Tours A8 en général mais
plutôt cette tour on a envie toujours un
peu peur de de lâcher la crème mais bon
aussi jouer tout revu
le droit de faire tous les affaires
[Musique]
mais c'est de faire à 4 prochains coups
c'est intéressant
tu vois et le coup normal mais je me
suis dit finalement peut-être Tour
Eiffel 8 justement à cause de ce pion à
7 qui peut traîner tu vois genre
admettons un truc comme ça je sais pas
je dis vraiment un truc un peu au hasard
Dame des 7 voilà par exemple à 3 menace
peut-être échec je sais pas menace de
pénétrer
j'en sais rien je vois pas le truc mais
disons que je me dis que c'est
pas complètement inconcevable qu'il y a
un truc ici pour les blancs
en 8 c'est que le pion à 7 pour être en
prison certaines variante donc
tout ouvrir B3 d'abord en général
parce que ces quatre en fait le problème
alors qu'avait les trois disons entouré
à 8 c'est 4 en tout ça on va prendre ici
prise puis une fois qu'on a on a qu'à
m'aider les Noirs là parce qu'on a
échangé ce cavalier le cavalier est
quand même très très stable ici
c'est en général rarement par contre B3
C4 c'est une vraie option parce que une
fois qu'on fait ces quatre on met la
pression ici parfois on menace des C5 et
tu commences à plus à trois avoir de
cases avec tes cavaliers si tu prends je
reprends du pion et tu as toujours pas
gagné la case des 5 donc ça c'est une
vraie c'est un vrai thème en fait dans
la position en tout cas intéressant
toutes les parties en débuté on va voir
Louis pink contre bananyamine Bock à
l'échiquier numéro 2
donc Benjamin BOC que je vais trouver
c'est une position assez spéciale quand
même celle là
et
on peut imaginer qu'il faut à trois qui
peut arriver OK
qu'on a ici alors ouais c'est étranges
ce qui s'est passé le 3 qui est 6 donc
on essaie d'éviter les grandes lignes
des quatre c'est une mer en normal on
joue trois bon jusque là rien de
rien d'extraordinaire petit normalement
on envoie la allez bonne nuit
en général
j'aime bien mais
tu fais crédit
pas ici puis on prend des quatre c'est
pris aussi par beniamine
il y a deux possibilités soit ça va être
un truc à base de reprise peut-être
qu'il y a des cinq cavaliers F4 quelque
chose comme ça soit le 4 voilà il a joué
et sur le 4 cavalue 5 j'avais du mal à
comprendre
au début il a fait des quatre moi je lui
ai fait confiance direct mais
c'est vrai qu'une fois que que tu le
vois c'est en temps bah oui
étrange peut-être pour 8 ah mais j'ai
quand même cavalé cette qui va arriver
un jour en fait
tu puisses tout manger non tu as pas le
temps de faire un
cavaler au 5 avaient les dessins de
cavaliers F4 se trouve un contrôle au
jeu comme ça mais
[Musique]
en plus j'ai l'impression
mais bon même sans les dames
[Musique]
chinois bonjour à tous Dans le chat là
ça faisait un moment que j'avais pas lu
ce n'est pas dit qu'il y a une
interprétation de du de l'achat de la
fusion je sais pas je sais pas comment
franchement je sais pas quelle
vocabulaire officiel de la fusion
acquisition parce que personne ne sait
ce que c'est donc c'est bien en fait tu
vois tu perds un peu tout le monde donc
voilà fusion acquisition cheesecom play
Magnus en tout cas très bien accueilli
voilà ils sont sympas ils sont sympas
au final
et salut Hakim et adopte people
alors kev6 qui est mal joué
d'après Gaïa qui vient d'arriver qui est
B6 qui vient d'être joué qui apparemment
pas un bon coup alors pourquoi
parce que du coup pour C4 attaques plus
tout le pion et Caval F4 c'est vrai que
c'est un vrai c'est un vrai une vraie
question pour le coup
après est-ce que je peux pas je pouvais
faire
tu m'as donné un peu de jeu peut-être
aussi sur C8 je sais pas des choses
comme ça il y a un peu de jeu est-ce
qu'on irait pas voir c'est dames allez
allons voir on va voir Juventus
comme on le voit à l'image et on va
bientôt voir à l'image notre ami la
jeune et apparemment très talentueuse
lit 14 ans
a priori si elle est là aussi
donc
et bien on a une sorte de double alors
ça je fais ça ouais
les 2e partie de ton Blitz tu sais en
fait tu sais les 2e tu sais quand la
fatigue commence à se faire sentir il y
a un double sur creto normalement qui
arrive à chaque partie
pour pouvoir jouer un peu en AutoPilote
bon et mais les Noirs ont pas si bien
réagi parce qu'on voit il y a quand même
ce légère avantage d'espace qui qui est
maintenu par les Blancs et donc c'est
toujours un peu désagréable on a un
petit avantage d'espace qui est pas
grave qui avait le 5 petites tactiques
sur qui est propre à me prendre
qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait la peur et non
elle est championne du monde prend des
cinq et regardez-moi ça ça ne va pas
pour les Noirs donc elle a joué cavalier
fuite ou qui est un peu un peu passif
faire
rouleau compresser
parce que si tu fais rien en fait
il faut réagir même si c'est pas
forcément le meilleur coup il faut
réagir
et donc prise prise dame G2 F3 mais
après son sur le foot B7
et maintenant comment on réagit
quand même beaucoup de pièces sur dessin
pas pousser je prends des 7
il y a le fou c'est le bon clouage alors
assez atypique
le de cloué comme ça avec le fou F3 et
la dame mangeait deux sur la grande
diagonale mais ça a l'air d'être assez
efficace et puis on menace tout
simplement de gagner un pion comment on
fait pour
ouais cavalier c'était pour protéger des
cinq et pousser ses cinq ouais
effectivement tout à fait
c'était pour menacer de pousser ses 5
pour protéger le puret 5 c'est vrai
c'est ça la pointe du coup maintenant on
comprend elle a re protéger des cinq une
fois et elle se le refait attaquer et
Damas 8
sur justement le lieu de faire C5
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal du tout
derrière
peut être aussi une option et elle a
joué
G4 et oui
encore un coup de pression en dessin
j'ai l'impression que tôt ou tard alors
je sais pas si c'est le coup mais en
tout cas jouer cavalier 4 va être
quasiment forcé est-ce qu'on le fait
directement on attend encore un coup
ça je n'en sais absolument rien
non mais surtout pour pas perdre de pion
parce que là je vois pas trop pour être
très honnête je vois pas trop de coups
utile pour les Noirs
[Musique]
tu peux aller là mais bon je vais
commencer je vais faire ça
je sais pas ça devient désagréable et
tout et qu'est-ce qui a été joué
elle a joué qui avait lieu aux quatre
voilà parce qu'elle voyait pas d'autre
coup non plus puis on prend puis on
prend ah d'abord puis on prend pourquoi
pourquoi parce que sur cavalier 4 c'est
le premier directement vous allez voir
la différence mais c'était pas terrible
tandis que là puis on prend un pion
prank et prend puis on prend fou 2 et
maintenant ce fou qui invente pouvez pas
venir ici attaquer F7 parce qu'elle a pu
aussi et un peu en C4 et bien maintenant
il a tout l'avenir il y a toute la vie
devant lui
le fou qui était qui était une mauvaise
pièce qui maintenant en fait vient
venir en C4 donc ça donne quand même la
case de cavalier en E6 mais le four en
C4 quand même fou C4 c'est 4 va être
joué quasiment certainement elle a joué
fousser 4 elle foutez 5 il est tellement
fort ce fou que tu reprendrais 5 ça se
regarde
une question débile à la place de
cavalier aussi bon ça c'est vraiment
cool un peu en pratique tu vois en blitz
etc mais la place de cavalier aussi
c'est ce que tu as pas un petit
peut-être c'est débile incomplet hein
tu prends une pièce n'importe laquelle
les bâches pions prend et là elle est
toutes les cartes blanches qui sont
autour de toi
je perd du matériel là tu m'as menti tu
m'as fait une publicité mensongère
toutes les cas s'ouvre et en plus tu
perds 3 pièces
cette histoire mais je peux pas prendre
en fait en vrai non mais tu fais rien
mais bon
contrôle
je crois que là
pour avoir du jeu mais effectivement
c'est un coup qui se regarde parce que
ça ouvre la grande diagonale c'est vrai
que la dame c'est un bon job hein en
défendant ces cases autour du roi donc
c'est l'idée qui pourrait qui pourrait
arriver tôt ou tard et à jouer cavalier
aussi sous ses quatre ou cinq fou des
cinq et dames c'est de très pro joue
même jaune pas de pas d'enflammage avec
tout reprendre et 5
pourquoi
c'est pas mal quand aussi il y a une
différence de niveau
par rapport à l'expérience tout ça c'est
intéressant il y a plein de décisions à
prendre avec les noirs et puis en plus
c'est un truc qu'on joue aussi sans trop
de prépa et donc c'est vrai que faut
avouer que vous en verrez plus online
que dans des droits de partir c'est pas
online en fait vous en avez plus d'un
étau à partir rapide quand on est droit
de pertinente parce que simplement c'est
une façon de simplement jouer aux échecs
voilà de sortir ces pièces d'être sûr de
pas être moins bien avec un peu de
chance on est un peu mieux et voilà
voilà ça joue c'est pas mal sicilienne
il faut voir que si on a rien préparé
l'autre il va jouer par exemple si vous
jouez MVN
bien vaut mieux avoir eu l'appariement à
l'avance parce qu'il joue c'est Nash
d'orve gone Feld mais si vous le savez
pas avant si vous arrivez devant la
partie vous jouez 4 ça nage d'or vous
avez pas le temps de vous préparer mais
lui ça fait ça fait 20 ans qu'il la
prépare son âge d'or donc c'est quand
même une assez mauvaise nouvelle donc
c'est pour ça que les doubles sur les
taux peuvent être pas mal parce que
souvent avec les Noirs je sais pas
comment ça marche pour toi mais c'est
vrai que avoir des droits de partir
rapide mais tu regardes si tu regardes
un petit peu tu regardes ton répertoire
avec les Noirs parce que les blancs il y
a tellement de possibilités pour les
noirs et tu vas être beaucoup plus au
point en tout cas c'est mon cas et
apparemment Stephen aussi je vais être
beaucoup plus au point d'un genre de
tournoi avec les Noirs parce que
j'aurais réviser un petit peu ma petite
espagnole mon petit gambidam et voilà je
serais content de et puis on est
toujours plus en difficulté avec les
noirs
donc ça c'est pour ça que ça a du sens
le double et F6 jouer par
Alice Lee oulalala que j'aime pas ça je
sais pas ce que tu en penses qu'il peut
arriver aussi c'est un calendrier
5 et dame prend la tête il y a toujours
des chèques qui peut faire très très mal
par contre est-ce que j'ai pas
est-ce que tu as pas tout
simplement et tourner
tu sais quoi pas mal aussi
c'est logique ouais c'était bien ça
aussi on reprend on monte vite fait et
là j'avais encore mes petits coups je
pensais aussi à cavaler les desserts on
reste dans la créa juste à avant
j'aime bien qui suis-je alors moi je
suis moi je suis un tu vois moi je suis
pas très imaginatif je te prends la
colonne tu vas là ou là je m'en moque et
je te fais un petit coup de dames et 4
et puis on s'arrange on s'arrange
gentiment
dans l'économie F5 jouer kg 5 et
maintenant elle joue tout reprend des
cinq nouvelles je ne te reprends
et on arrête la pendule et on félicite
son adversaire tour des 8 jouets mais
évidemment que j'ouvre elle l'a vu tout
ça il faut prendre des cinq jouets très
vite je veux une jaune qui ne rigole pas
et ça va faire un point pour les Chinois
et nul encore
grosse grosse partie hein facile en plus
tu as l'impression que c'est facile ce
qu'elle a fait avec les Blancs
elle a pas sueur ça c'est sûr là elle a
joué sur sa classe et qui est qui est
immense
comme tu l'as dit en plus on a Dominguez
qui a fait nul ouais donc là c'est gagné
encore si non non ouais ils sont un peu
là ils ont déjà fait un match
qui était en galère et qu'il est
toujours dans cette filière de foot
qu'on reposer mais ce qui s'en serait
pas sorti Stéphane ici alors
ça redescent parce que je te colle
d'abord un piano ouais c'est ça et
attention et quand c'est proche comme ça
je suis trop B6 alors Foubert faut faire
fugueur la vitesse de l'éclair à mon
avis la seule chance de s'en sortir
c'est un scénario comme ça
donc je vais je vais attendre
dans tous les sens ok ça va pas
c'est horrible et fou B3 là il y a des
six qui va arriver c'est certain alors
comment on fait là est-ce qu'on a une
moyenne non je crois pas
je crois vraiment et à la place
j'ai pas le temps de faire un voyage
quand même pas jouer non trop dur parce
que je mets le roi en dessin
ouais je vais jouer peut-être pas tout
de suite parce que je suis un peu
heureux j'ai peur de B4 au bout
d'ailleurs je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
peur je te le prends voilà donc là ouais
je vais même peut-être ressortir avec le
roi voilà ça fait ça fait tout brillant
elle va il va l'emporter c'est
exactement la vente qu'on a vu où on va
mettre ah ouais c'est un roi cinq
saisons si on bouge le fou on fait des 7
et ensuite on a deux pions passé lié
et si on fait
on fait ça et si tu fais roi des sèches
je te suis et là ces exemples c'est
terminé
[Musique]
pour se moquer de mon adversaire
on a quand même besoin du roi à un
moment ou un autre
mais effectivement là ça termine le
travail facilement est-ce qu'il
resterait pas une partie plus
intéressante il reste que deux parties
on va aller voir François
Gagné et je vais gagner donc c'était
gagnant donc on va aller voir joue la
partie simple c'est
des blancs et là ça a l'air d'être
gagnant en un coup ces pièces de plus
Caval et bouge j'ai faux F3 échec qui va
manger à 8 donc il est là il est blanc
petit après-midi pour Théodore avec la
première archi gagnante et là il se
prend une bulle
après la joue comme son numéro 1 donc ok
avec les Noirs c'est pas simple mais bon
encore deux parties
en fait c'est un peu comme hier à Macar
en fait parce que ton leader c'est ton
leader se fait neutraliser en fait c'est
bien d'avoir un super fort devant mais
si c'est neutralisé en fait ben c'est
pas si simple derrière il te manque du
monde quand même
est-ce qu'on a des chances de sauver
cette finale j'y crois pas
non c'est terminé mais ça reste quand
même attends il a cinq secondes
donc ça reste quand même énorme du
limite c'est un blitz tout simplement
de partout je pense que
j'ai l'impression que c'est trop facile
mais c'est vrai que là j'ai pas aimé
c'est plus de temps je serai d'accord
avec toi mais je suis pas d'accord je
trouve ça je trouve ça dur à gérer en
avec simplement l'incrément de 2
secondes par coup maintenant il joue sur
ça
il faut jouer là
il faut jouer ça
il est la veille il est cloué tu peux
pousser huit
quand même la Kardashian au cas où ouais
c'est vrai mais
sur ce pion et j'ai l'impression qu'on
se venge on se venge sur les pions ça y
est
oh là là la cata pour vie et oui qui a
perdu le contrôle là mais c'est
pas évident encore une fois à moins qui
est
la salle de bain par contre
ou pas
ça joue deux secondes d'incrément donc
faut être faut être gentil avec les
joueurs
de ouf le plus perdu
mais non mais comme tu l'as dit en fait
les gens sont très mal au temps et c'est
très dur pour les deux joueurs en fait
tu as vu il a tous les deux pions il y a
trois pions finalement il a donné un fou
et déjà qu'il avait pas il avait pas le
sourire il avait pas l'air mort de rire
Théodore
deuxième coup sur la tête bon dur dur 2
et demi-heure et demi pour nos amis
chinois et bien écoute ça fait ça fait
du 5 à 3 alors c'est pas encore c'est
pas encore appuyé là mais je veux une
journée elle a pas terminé sa partie
c'est pas possible
mais non mais non attends tu vas pas tu
vas pas le croire
elle est foutue non
ce n'est pas possible on était en train
de vanter la classe de Juventus
qui est là qu'on va voir à l'écran
on va on va voir ça au ralenti tout à
l'heure
et 15 secondes contre 20 c'est injouable
incroyable j'ouvre le jeu qui a perdu le
contrôle
[Musique]
et ça va être abandon du coup
une fois
qu'on vient elle joue bien là mon
prochain coup c'est terminé
c'est fini
elle joue elle joue par dépit mais on va
voir on va voir ce qui s'est passé alors
là c'est un plus aucun intérêt
mais qu'est-ce comment elle a fait pour
rater ça
alors on en était où là
on s'est dit bon on va le faire
confiance la classe de la championne du
monde
je comprends pas
du coup
quand je peux ne pas en donner je joue
ça moi
et puis
comme comme des champs on joue en dehors
on fait rentrer défenseur et oui F2 là
le film pour rien dommage
elle a un petit peu et là ça y est alors
effectivement c'est pas méchant méchant
mais déjà on peut plus aller on peut
plus aller carotter le pion en 7
elle a complètement craqué en me disant
mais c'est hallucinant ce qu'elle a fait
la championne du monde comme quoi vous
voyez hein elle a joué les 20 pro et les
25 premiers coups niveau incroyable et
là elle s'est relâché trop tôt
apparemment c'était gagnant
c'était gagnant comment il fallait jouer
C4 C4 pour protéger puis on prend foin
F2 et ensuite on pousse et c'est
complètement terminé d'après la jauge
incroyable fu F4 F6 énorme gaffe bon là
c'est note et à ces deux nouveaux
gagnants apparemment F6 il y avait
encore un gain pour les noirs qui
étaient E3 bah c'est pas hyper étonnant
mon ascavalie F2 et si on fait F7
cavalier F2 si on va en géant il y a H2
H1 dame et si on prend et bien je
suppose qu'on fait simplement puis on
prend tu fais tourner un et là mauvaise
nouvelle je protège je fais roi E2 et je
fais dames et je
fais ce que je veux en fait
[Musique]
et fini et dernier coup quand même bien
joué son truc de son truc de tourgé
c'est parce que là là ça aurait pu être
drôle quand même
[Musique]
incroyable
incroyable attends je mets la parce que
là je mets un gars
sur H2 sur H2 tu joues deux non ça
marche pas en fait là tu veux plus
d'amener parce que
et du coup
ok alors ce que je te propose il nous
reste attends on va faire un point
disant ça a failli ça a failli changer
il y a 5 3 moi je te propose à cette à
cette mi-temps du match rester avec nous
parce que c'est parti quand même ça en
plus elle dure tu vois on est déjà c'est
vraiment des belles parties on aura
évidemment le deuxième match à 19h on va
faire un léger
petit break
et on revient un petit break musical
musique choisie par Kevin thérieux et
oui le DJ bon on a les goûts on a les
goûts qu'on peut on fait ce qu'on peut à
tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour si mon micro
c'est pas débranché du bon du bon truc
mais je crois que tout va bien
à part que les joueurs
les joueurs n'arrêtent pas de changer de
couleur Stéphane
donc du coup on va tous on va tous se
remettre un petit truc comme ça on va
mettre personne et on va attendre que
les parties commencent tu me dis quand
ça commence mais pendant ce temps des
Chinois pour l'instant on les voit
Shanghai Tiger qui ont tout simplement
pardon qui ont qui domine qui sont deux
points d'avance là à amis parcours de
points d'avance mais attention que du
coup si les Shanghai Tigers gagné avec
plus de deux points d'avance lors de la
prochaine partie
tu vas nous les donner d'ailleurs
alors du coup pour ça
on va avoir 43 c'est bien
donc Joe la championne du monde
avec les blancs du coup contre liner
Dominguez
on va voir aussi oui avec les Blancs
contre Benjamin Bocq là on voit vraiment
les niveaux qui se resserre un peu on a
aussi tu as le 3 Nicolas théodoro contre
Louis
et au dernier on a Alice Lee avec les
Blancs contre
une maladie
je pense qu'à la fin du tournoi ça ira
mieux donc ça c'est apparemment de la
ronde ça c'est pas sûr
et enfin je parle pour moi là je parle à
voix haute donc tu disais veille elle
est blanche
oui
ça c'est une bonne nouvelle ça
parce que tu as
en fait c'est les deux premiers en fait
si tu veux les deux premiers élo et les
deux il est 3 4 et Ben sont toujours le
même couleur en même temps donc
on peut
OK et ça va bientôt ça va bientôt
démarrer on va démarrer là je vais
regarder les Chinois il a raison Mogo
et
ça a commencé
ils sont très très balaise ça c'est sûr
ça a commencé que j'ai d'ailleurs alors
j'avais
commencé comme une partie de bookage
comme ça
et je crois que c'était contre un
Arménien
Guess voilà on les voit à l'écran
non on le voit pas l'écran
ah ouais alors ça c'est connu c'est
connu elle propose
non
comme moi ont essayé de chercher quelque
chose ici en fait c'est ça que je me
demandais pas pourquoi
et on fait tout 8 et on va prendre 3 et
tout va bien si on connaît un petit peu
mais Dominique évidemment qui va
connaître tout ça
pourquoi on peut faire ah oui en fait on
fait pas voilà c'est très c'est ça la
raison c'est que surtout
et on égalise alors il faut faire un
petit peu attention parce qu'il y a
quand même des essais pour les blancs du
style un coup comme F4 F5 ici pour jouer
contre le foot casse noir et le foot
casse blanche pardon mais en général les
Noirs ont montré l'antidote
Domingues c'est pas genre à pas
connaître mais bon il réfléchit
donc pourquoi pas maintenant une nulle
dans celle-là je pense que les Chinois
tu vois je sais pas s'il y a des
consignes mais en tout cas je pense que
Juventus a l'air plutôt
satisfaitement donc je sais pas ce qui
arrive mais elle a l'air contente
pas hyper inquiète ensuite on a
veillé donc Benjamin Bocq avec les
Blancs
contre Benjamin Boch
on va voir que vous allez apparaître
vous allez voir apparaître
avec les Blancs la dame est mal placée
mais d'un côté on a une position quand
même qui se joue ou à pour attaquer donc
[Musique]
éventuellement pour l'instant on peut
pas y aller mais ça pose des petits
problèmes pour les Noirs sachant que si
on a le coup qui qu'on a envie de jouer
ici c'était 5 mais faut toujours faire
attention à ce vis-à-vis qui est
dangereux typiquement un truc comme ça
alors ça se calcule alors mais un truc
comme ça a l'air de quand même perdre
pour pour les Noirs pas assez de menace
pas maths on peut prendre ici et on va
s'enfuir avec le roi ça devrait aller
donc attention à des 5 et c'est vrai que
l'attaque l'attaque blanche peut aller
peut aller très très vite j'ai 5 j'ai 4G
5 au 2 prochains coups
écoute on va avoir une belle partie la
vie qui joue
qui met la pression là pour le coup
d'avance
si vous jouez comme ça faut les
connaître parce que si vous jouez dams
sans connaître c'est chaud donc faut
quand même mieux savoir ce qu'on fait et
veillez c'est absolument ce qui fait
est-ce que les toutes les parties ont
reprises donc on a Nicolas théodoro qui
est malheureux pour le moment alors
Nicolas théodoro que je vais vous
retrouver
en suivant il est là décorateur
de la part de Dominguez à la place de
cavalier G4
on va aller voir tu vas aller voir non
j'ai 6
ça fait bizarre d'ouvrir le classement
alors que tu vas jouer quand même les
caméras cette fois
mais c'est vrai que c'est il veut F5 et
Caval le 4 pour manger le le fou le foot
casse blanche bah écoute en tout cas
jouer un jeu elle joue vite elle a l'air
de
je sais pas ce qu'elle connaît ou pas
mais en tout cas la loi assez vite
est-ce que ça suffisant
mais bon après encore une fois dans
l'esprit du match
tenir en échec de linguez pas mal
je sais je sais que c'est pas la bonne
caméra on va avoir tourné chez théodoro
partout donc il parle de l'équipe de
Kevin je pense on jouait hier ils ont
joué hier ils ont gagné contre les
Indiens et je sais pas quand est-ce
qu'ils vont rejouer du coup on n'a pas
les dates en tout cas moi je sais pas
donc voilà on n'a pas plus de nouvelles
que ça en tout cas ils ont gagné et ça
c'était c'était bien
la fin du stream c'était c'était assez
drôle
[Rires]
[Musique]
qui peut rentrer
donc grosse équipe et voilà après si se
qualifie je pense que ils vont
d'ailleurs réussir se qualifier dans les
8 premiers c'est les matchs coupés donc
match couper bon bah tout peut arriver
bon c'est pas mal ça pour Théodore moi
j'aime bien ça ça catalane Louis pink
qui vient de faire une partie
il m'a pas l'air d'être le point fort de
l'équipe là peut-être
Louis pink va falloir le viser
c'est du 10 plus 2 mauvais alors ça peut
paraître
c'est vrai que on peut avoir
l'impression qu'il joue de manière très
rapide mais le problème c'est que
l'incrément est vraiment très petit
donc ça se tient aussi hein
à la fin ça je l'ai raté ok
voilà
le cavalier
non seulement
c'est juste bizarre mais
bon vraiment pas terrible là je pense
que cavaliero 4 va arriver mais bon
théodoru en souffrance aussi il a raté
une position archi gagnante dans la
première la deuxième il a perdu donc
c'est une partie très très importante
pour les pour l'équipe de Saint-Louis là
il faut absolument que Théodore se
réveille
deux points de retard et puis et puis
ils ont toujours ce ticket chez qui au 4
là où Alice liens elle fait ce qu'elle
peut franchement mais mais elle joue
beaucoup vraiment une adversité très
très forte tout à fait et on va la voir
normalement à la caméra à l'isley
seulement elle est vraiment
très prometteuse mais
mais bon elle a 200 points que tous ses
adversaires
c'est qui ça s'exui
mais je crois que c'était comme ça qu'on
avait fait
et comme tu dis bah écoute elle est pas
mal quand même avec potentiellement de
l'attaque
alors comment est-ce qu'on joue ici
toujours pas un petit une sorte de G4
pour essayer de après te mettre en
cabane en F3 tout ça
et ce F4 aussi
du mal à faire à faire le 5 direct à Don
d'avoir un appui avec le pion F4 et
cet orage 45
c'est qu'on attaque ici on menace aussi
pour un chien
donc pas évident avec le roi qui paraît
un peu dans les courants d'air là
de faire un peu de ménage par là en plus
tu deviens un petit peu la dame et il
faut penser trop et jouer ah bah j'ai
dit tu dis un petit peu Adam elle a fait
elle avait pris mauve puis on prend ses
trois Alicia elle rigole pas elle rigole
pas parce qu'on a pas trop envie quand
même de prendre du pion parce que c'est
vrai que ça peut créer des C5 des
colonnes C qui s'ouvrent le roi devient
faible sur le long terme quoique on peut
le mettre là peut-être donc ça se tient
pas trop toi qui est pas trop à
l'amateur de PRIMOVE de trucs comme ça
qu'est-ce que tu as un problème ça va
mais bon c'est quand même décision c'est
pas le prix nous tu sais où ce qui est
vraiment forcé quoi c'est possible
c'est quand même un poil un poil quand
même
[Musique]
responsable
très très responsable clairement et tout
surprenant ouais c'est ça
des idées de ramener la dame par là-bas
ouais c'est 5 ouais mais effectivement
là elle a eu le temps de réfléchir sur
le temps de son adversaire donc elle
peut se décider à prix mauvais puis on
pensait trop
les croco
alors Championnat du Monde c'est pas
avec les vélos de chasse comme
malheureusement c'est c'est pas comme ça
qu'on se qualifie mais sache que les
joueurs qui vont au championnat du monde
ils ont passé la meilleure joue du monde
donc sur cheesecom c'est quoi c'est 3000
après c'est assez démocratique pour se
qualifier pour pour un match championnat
du monde je crois on peut commencer par
le championnat national ensuite on peut
se qualifier pour le championnat
d'Europe ensuite au championnat d'Europe
pianiste pour la Coupe du Monde ensuite
à la Coupe du Monde on peut se qualifier
pour les candidats ensuite il faut
gagner les candidats et ensuite on peut
jouer pour le titre de champion du monde
mais il y a moyen mais c'est long en
gros la route est longue et ici il faut
à peu près 2800 hello en classement
classement feed et actuellement de 800
hello il y en a qu'un seul
c'est à peu près ça
le PC derrière c'est vrai que ça peut
être un petit peu étrange mais parfois
il demande de caméra voilà pour toujours
pareil être sûr du fair-play
entre entre les joueurs là ça joue quand
même c'est pas une compétition de
quartier donc c'est la progesse League
la
le plus grand tournoi online par équipe
clairement bon
il y a quand même des prix conséquent là
j'ai pas montré aujourd'hui mais 150000
dollars de prix je crois que c'est 25000
à la première équipe comme ça ouais
voilà donc 150 millions de prix au
global bon donc on fait on fait un petit
peu attention quand même offert play
évidemment
donc au moins tout au 4 elle mérite de
fermer cette diagonale
ok mais puis on prend environ
alors en montre l'idée principale sur G4
on fait échec le roi vient où il veut ça
change rien et on va faire le tour H1
quasimat rouge et mieux mais ça
changeait pas ça change rien l'histoire
et là il joue tout revu
tu vois là maintenant toi
maintenant après quand même j'attaque la
dame le pion sur trois derrière ah ben
je vais essayer de pas le filer tant
qu'à faire
mais bon
attention attention les yeux ça peut
venir très très vite
mais c'est vrai qu'une position
d'attaque tu es en pleine défense
l'enfer et en plus là tu vas même que
l'option de plus que tu as c'est un pion
quand j'ai deux ou G3 et c'est un pion
qui qui représentait en fait exactement
[Musique]
ont pris clairement le dessus là elle a
pris du cavalier Alice OK
je sais pas pourquoi d'ailleurs
peut-être
ça ça
va G7 mais attention qui est projet 5
tours de trois jouets elle est
passionnante cette partie écoute à moi
qui moi je serai tenté de mettre un
énorme coup de frein là
énorme coup de frein mais la finale elle
est pas terrible on va pas se mentir le
roi qui se balade c'est normal au final
et la structure des noirs et elle est
parfaite
jouer c'est le seul coup légal avec
l'abandon
et acceptation mais pas de raison non
plus parce qu'on commence à aimer les
Noirs non
clairement qu'est-ce qu'on joue là je
sais pas
il y avait
je sais pas c'est pas évident
je te fais mon tour
[Musique]
des trois dernières
et la dame qui défend ah mais je te
reprends les trois d'un point H5
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
ici il s'est passé et de coupure menace
cavalier H7 protège ses C3 et dame G6
joué Parks
une une finale de manière malhonnête il
est bien raison est-ce que plus
tu vas pouvoir réussir à faire quelque
chose toute façon à part d'un projet 6
qu'est-ce qu'il y a je crois que c'est
quasi obligé
de faire un truc
pas mal et peut-être qu'un wifi
sa troisième partie ouais
cette partie dame prendra tout à cette
ton coup je vais par Alice lit ok le
pack le roi s'échappe couteau recette
main obligatoire parce que là Tour
Eiffel
c'est quasiment pas de partout
alors laquelle c'est ça la question
est-ce que ça change quelque chose à la
et oui ça change parce que maintenant
j'ai assez trop en prise pas du tout
pareil et G3 aussi par exemple tu
reprends ton reprend kb6 pour imaginer
tous ces pions en l'air
ça fait pas plaisir
le cavalier en plus après
qui revient à la même conclusion qui
joue ok ça a beaucoup plus de sens parce
que on garde cette tour 3 qui est plus
active alors on sait pas si ça va être
utile mais par
principe on garde la tour active tout
simplement on se fait un petit tour
alors
dominez contre zoom
sans surprise ça va faire nul ok
0 pions de plus beau contre VI écoute
qu'est-ce que ça donne elle menacée
d'être là cette partie elle est folle on
va les mettre à l'écran peut-être nos
amis
donc c'est une belle idée avec un
camping du centre peut-être 5 D4
et qu'un thème C4 qu'on avait jamais vu
moi je connaissais pas
donc là vraiment c'est quoi 3 4 5 3 4 5
6 5 noirs c'était pas vraiment une
menace la prend ces quatre étapes
mais comme j'avais déjà un pion de moi
et ben du coup les blancs sont pas
intéressés là on voit aussi que que le
Blanc joue pour le match donc
si on compare les rois on comprend que
bon on n'a pas envie d'échanger les
pièces ok j'ai trois fous français de
c'est hyper compliqué 20 secondes
simplement pour BOC apparemment français
est une gaffe mais c'est tellement dur
cette position tellement dur à jouer
j'ai l'impression même un peu comme
tourcéen et après on va prendre là si tu
prends là tu m'ouvres ouh là il y a des
princesses aussi oulala jouer
mais alors là j'ai l'impression même
qu'elle prend H5 pions prend obligé
parce que attention ok G7
c'est la partie
B4 mais après quoi le 5
quel sens voilà moi je suis un peu
heureux je fais ça moi je fais ça et
comme ça surpuis on prend je fais ça
mais
ouais mais il va trouver un truc plus
net là j'ai l'impression ok
ça pourrait jouer sur ça
ça va être
énorme ça a l'air complètement c'est
complètement c'est sûr c'est sûr c'est
complètement admet on prend
j'aime bien j'aime bien ça tourne se
débrouiller ah non F7
faut prendre
la tête
c'est ça c'est la partie
de l'ancien prodige VI en voie théodoru
aller chez qui numéro 3
qui est un légère avantage contre le
hipping mais ça devrait pas suffire je
sais pas ce que tu en penses
et on va
peut-être on verra mais en tout cas on
va revenir à cette partie qui était
qu'on a suivi là qui était une belle
partie
d'Alice Lee qui est là que je vais
retrouver sous vos yeux
face à
à tous les pions qui tournent les uns
après les autres en fait ici elle a pas
réussi à obtenir du jeu ça va colonage
était plus peut-être et regarder le 3 et
demi dont tu parlais attention si
t'esodoruf encore un cadeau c'est
terminé
il y a 6 et demi là elle va perdre
la couleur assez
il a fait quelques quelques craquages
il est perdu maintenant par contre si la
partie continue enfin si il part en fait
il y aura un quatrième set 4e
on peut on peut essayer de mentir et
dire que c'est chaud mais je crois que
personne va nous croire
qu'ils ont gagné une partie individuelle
[Musique]
qui a perdu la partie d'avant avec son
fameux
[Musique]
la partie avec le D4 eux prend des
quatre quatre qui avaient le 5 ah oui
exactement contre Louis ils ont fait nul
donc on a un dernier set ok alors il y a
7 à 4 là pour les Shanghai Tiger
faudrait qu'il sauve ça normal sauf ça
elle peut pas sauver ça ça va faire 8 à
c'est vraiment
aller chinois qui montent encore une
fois qu'ils ont réservoir de joueurs
assez impressionnant
on les connaît pas mais par veiller ça
fait déjà à moitié d'équipe les deux
autres on les connaissait pas mais alors
c'est pas des
mais en fait les mecs ils sont hyper
chauds
ils sont hyper chaud c'est assez c'est
assez bluffant
tout doit gagner
ouais
c'est la 5 secondes avec les Blancs
il va y avoir G5 voilà je le connais par
cœur
moi je les connaissais en fait moi je le
connaissais
bien sûr monsieur évidemment
alors question question intéressante les
chaises bref aussi l'animé Magnus et
Guillaume au premier certainement mais
alors va falloir va falloir qu'on penser
par des joueurs beaucoup moins bien
classés mais effectivement ça peut être
difficile quelque chose ça fait 2700700
ouais mais c'est comme greachu que ML
finalement c'est ça
ok donc là c'est vraiment terminé et
elle a abandonné à l'Isly on va faire un
point
un point classement mais regardez-moi ça
8 à 4 pour les Shanghai Tiger ce qui
aura besoin d'une nul pour emporter ce
match autant vous dire que on attend le
premier le prochain match avec un
passeport pour évidemment regarder ce
dernier ce dernier set mais il y a on a
un autre match qui arrive à 19h
qui sera entre nos amis
les donc c'est les Croates et contre les
Américains encore une fois et je
voudrais bien qu'ils sont nombreux dans
le championnat
je vais
tout de suite vous je vais vous le
mettre voilà on va se faire un petit
pour ceux qui ont pas envie de regarder
le dernier le dernier match on va on va
faire un petit un petit un petit teasing
qu'est-ce que tu en penses Stéphane
vous allez avoir à l'écran que la
technique ici de Laurent incroyable
pour l'instant on voyait rien mais là je
suis impressionné alors
donc on a avec les enfin on a la
première échiquier de l'équipe croate on
a Bogdan de hack donc c'est un jeune
roumain
qui doit avoir 18 ans je pense au plus
un peu plus ah ben moi j'ai joué en 2016
donc il a déjà 2006 alors je veux bien
il y a 6 ans il y avait pas 12 ans non
non il a plus ok ok ok il y a plus il a
été très très fort jeune aussi
il y avait pas 12 ans c'est super
donc bon 2400 hello en tout cas il est
il a il est passé 2007 il y a pas il y a
pas longtemps hein du tout et donc bon
c'est la costa montante
roumaine et derrière on a ben livaïque
qui est qui monte aussi hein il est
jeune il doit avoir l'avantage je pense
ok je pensais qu'il est plus déjà
il fait un peu plus que son âge
après
le troisième je connais pas du tout
dernier
j'ai envie de dire
bon ça fait peur
après on verra ce qu'il veut mais
il fait peur et puis bah Polina chou
valova je pense que tu vas la connaître
alors c'est super elle joue à un style
super à suivre et on voit tout et après
le voir elle voit ce qui se passe donc
on va voir des parties marrantes avec
chevalova ça c'est enfin des parties
dynamiques
très très dynamique ça va être
intéressant et en face on a donc Ray
Robson alors évidemment très connu
aerobson 2700 hello Alors lui c'était un
enfant prodige pour le coup
donc 2700 très fort Darius search qui
vit maintenant aux États-Unis tout comme
girlg Myers très connu
un expert de ces
de ces tournois online Georg donc très
très bon joueur déjà très très bon
joueur tout court et encore plus sur
internet donc là ils ont réussi à
aligner quand même trois joueurs alors
un à plus de 2007 et 2 joueurs à plus de
2006 il mise finalement pas sur une
grande star une autre grande star 2016
mais finalement deux joueurs très
solides à plus de 2006 c'est une autre
stratégie ça sera intéressant et Sabina
foessor très connu aussi
2196 ça ça m'étonne un peu son
classement parce que je pense pas
en 2003 woman grande master onegrand
Master 2003 non oui oui 23 50 même il
faut avoir
je suis quasiment sûr
il faut avoir au moins une fois 2350
donc c'est quand même je crois qu'on va
parler on va parier
vas-y vas-y vas-y on regarde pas regarde
pas
Google et on a gagné sur le sur le chat
Sébastien encore là c'est une arbitre
feed alors peut-être que les habits tu
fais confiance
à chaque fois qu'il me disent un truc
alors si vous êtes arbitre si vous
marbrés un jour sachez que vous ne
pourrez pas bluffer parce que je vérifie
toujours tout ce qu'on me dit
voilà et surtout quand ça vient d'un
arbitre 2300
mettre de la fellation des échecs non
la perte de 1400 la perte pour être pour
faire une arme de grand-mère féminin
c'est de 1400
mais du coup le hello doit être plus bas
c'est le quiz c'est un peu comme comme
les hommes là 2006 pour être un homme de
grand-mère
il faut une fois c'est 2450 et 2004
donc il y a 50 points simplement
elle marche pas à ton histoire
quand même
je vois pas je trouve pas ça c'est
incroyable moi
[Rires]
vous savez combien il faut pour avoir
pour être grand
on doit avoir sur la sur la fille non ça
c'est incroyable je marque le titre
conditions
[Musique]
elles peuvent l'obtenir la tenir un
classement fidèle d'au moins
2 3
hello en classique
ouais mais moi j'ai toujours l'air de
moi
ce qui me connaissent bien le savent je
perds quasiment tous mes Paris donc
c'est mon bon client je peux remercier
d'exister mais non mais en fait quand tu
parles rien tu gagnes c'est ça
j'adore parier et je perds tout c'est
juste donc si tu veux que je vois ce
quelqu'un c'est simple il faut que je
parie dessus et non mais ça j'étais
quasi sûr en plus en fait même
les filles pour être maître il faut 2200
et l'eau donc ça va quand même 100
points de plus que 2003 même par rapport
aux hommes c'est 2004 2005 mettre
ça m'a je sais pas
[Musique]
donc on aura du coup avec les Blancs
liner Dominguez contre Wailly OK
je suis prêt à prendre
en plus il est cubain quoi
hispanique mais je sais pas quoi se
prononce non je parlerai pas dans le
doute
alors on va faire ça ça ensuite on aura
en fait elles apparaît vraiment sur le
stream là qui sont déjà affichés
Benjamin BOC avec les Blancs contre tout
ils sont sur le stream mais bon après
todoro elle est blanche ok ça c'est ça
[Musique]
il s'affiche l'équipe donc il est noir
elle est blanche c'est bon contre Joan
c'est noir
et théodoro il aura les noirs et après
en fait les deux sont versés les deux
derniers sont versés
parce que c'est une équipe à droite une
équipe à gauche
et
un test pour voir s'il est la technique
suites
c'est propre alors on va commencer les
parties
là quand même à suivre un petit G5
peut-être arrivé en tout cas bon c'est
ma un qui fait une nulle le match est
terminé donc est-ce que tu penses qu'il
va y avoir au lit
pourquoi pas en fait tu perds pas de
points à l'eau oui mais dans le sens
qu'en fait oui est-ce qu'il va balancer
son petit gs5 essayer d'aller
[Musique]
donc les noirs
et pour l'instant on laisse nos amis
[Musique]
et Bob
en anglais j'ouvre une journée
et
du coup on va avoir après
sous
contre théodoru qui est pas encore
commencé
quand ça joue vite en tout cas la partie
de box après moi on dit rien c'est ouf
on va voir on va voir la partie de box
tout de suite
il y a eu
C4 les Noirs ont joué des 4
ok E4 pour tout
je comprends pas pourquoi
depuis
pendant le match
et
[Musique]
à partir de censé être une
une
carte avec les noirs
C3 V4 donc forcément connaitre
ici mais je parle pas de cette ligne là
parler d'une autre partie du
bking D3 full G7 H3 alors ça ça en
connaît un peu dame C7
donc là oui ça c'est donc il y a eu un
bouquin à écrit par notre ami Adrien de
but sur la rétine
tout à fait donc voilà B4 c'était avant
moi je suis pas un spécialiste en tout
Arthur
mais après
moi je suis pas trop un bosseur de base
et
généralement les bouquins je les lis
quand je suis dans les transports
[Musique]
et je voilà mais sinon je suis pas un
gros lecteur
mais
à un moment donné j'avais envie
d'essayer de bosser un peu ça c'est vrai
que c'est un truc magique qui m'a
toujours un peu un peu plus type de
position c'est pas mon style je suis
quand même
j'avais essayé de jouer l'anglaise
pendant quasiment un an et ça ça se
passait pas bien c'est toujours de
balancer un petit G4 à un moment donné
parce que j'en pouvais plus quoi mais
bon ça allait pas que la position tu
sais mais j'arrive vraiment à me à
résister à très zoner donc pour éviter
tout est normal une bénonie inversée un
peu bizarre et là E4 quoi intermédiaire
jolie par jouer le jeu mais est-ce que
ça marche
parce que j'ai pas compris ce qui s'est
passé
[Musique]
avec les Noirs
je mange là
les pions sont un peu faibles ok donc
très jolie coup
maintenant ce pion a l'air
si c'est pas condamné on n'est pas loin
très forte
notamment j'aime bien les blancs alors
peut-être alors peut-être cette
remontada on va voir allez il va être
parti qu'est-ce qu'on a alors solimaux
tu parlais d'une B4 ouais c'était la
Lauru donc Théodore
il est bon endroit ouais Théodore il est
bon endroit alors
on voit pas pour l'instant il va
apparaître bientôt
il va apparaître bientôt
et
intéressant Rosso limo écoute Théodore
ton truc
chez les américains ils y croient
ils ont pas le choix il faut il faut
tenter pourquoi pas il faut tenter et
ici du coup alors un peu le début il y a
eu un petit C3 BK
développement pour se cavalier donc on
va essayer de se développer comme ça
mais
je paye personne avec les Blancs ce
genre de truc qui a trois pour faire 4
pourquoi pas B5 logique
ok
on a l'impression qu'on regagne une
pièce mais il y a le petit coin
intermédiaire qui nous perdra
et on attaque et on va revenir gentiment
et on a gagné une pièce donc attention
et c'est de fou B7 et oui on met les
deux fous sur la grande diagonale on
sait jamais ça peut faire mal
il a une faiblesse ici mais c'est quoi
un petit peu il a bien raison sur le roi
c'est vrai que c'est normal d'ouvrir le
centre ici
F5 sur prise pour prendre et cavalier la
barre de fou qui va jouer donc on sait
pas encore comment exactement mais un
plan ce type là
et F8 aussi qui viendra un moment donné
on fait attention ne pas perdre des 7 ou
par un tas de racisme mais après bon
même là je peux peut-être c'est quoi on
peut on peut le donner la plupart du
temps
moi j'aime pas du tout parce que ça
ouvre la
d'un coup d'un seul en fait t'ouvre la
colonne fouvre la grande diagonale ça me
plaît pas ça me plaît pas vraiment si je
devais faire un coup comme ça je ferai
vraiment
tu vois en dernière recours ça c'est
rien d'autre à faire si je pars
mais je serais comme notre ami
souris qui a 4 minutes tu vois contre
neuf et bien embêté en vrai parce que
les trois il y a cavalier
et là je me la Scave lui de la prison 4
de pions je sais pas j'essaierai de
faire marcher ces cartes je pense comme
ça pour essayer de me
mais est-ce que je j'arriverai vraiment
je crois pas je vois pas
5 oui par exemple
je sais pas donc après potentiellement
de zéro
attention
là je commence à être très sérieux là
en plus wahi qui a fait grand rock qui a
balancé des pions
GHE c'est une partie où il peut passer
absolument tout et n'importe quoi
3-0 pour Saint-Louis
incroyable qu'elle remontée
et la dernière partie on l'a pas vu on
l'a vu ou pas Benjamin Bocq contre
juvenjoon
et là j'aime bien les Noirs j'ai
l'impression que que les Blancs ont pas
obtenu ce qu'ils ont généralement dans
un ressort peut-être que je peux avoir
du
un moment donné
F4
[Musique]
c'est quasi
on va avoir des départages incroyables
pour l'instant mais là ça pue le 4 0
cette histoire je vous le dis
on va voir on va voir mais bon
ouais allez Alice
et contre le hipping qui a pas été
impérial dans ce match c'est peut-être
le seul chinois qui a montré quand même
des signes de faiblesse
assez régulier Dame des 7 et regarde-moi
ça elle a quand même toute initiative
c'est la rosoliemo
deluxeaux je peux vous dire ça se passe
pas souvent comme ça Immo qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est fou dessin pour éviter les
nouvelles donc j'ai 6 le coup le plus
joué on a vu aussi tout à l'heure j'ai 6
bien entendu jouer par Magnus Carlson
dans son match champion du monde face à
Fabiano Carola en 2018 fougez 7
après mais fougère beaucoup tout à fait
normal la nuit c'est un petit peu on a
envie de faire 5 et cavalier F6 parfois
comme elle a fait cavalier 7 pour
pouvoir faire F5 ça c'est la vente
agressive
et à 3 alors à 3 cette thématique pour
essayer de faire B4 alors ça peut ça
peut paraître bizarre comme concept
d'échanger et puis en doubler mais ça
donne ça donne beaucoup de jeux pour les
blancs sur la Colona et après on a du
mal toujours à se développer avec les
Noirs donc on l'empêche il faut trois B6
et on va jouer pour ce plan avec tyrock
qui F5 même des deux
et H6 aussi qui existe
pour faire F5 ensuite
le courant qu'on joue généralement HC1
H6 pour empêcher
F4 aussi souvent ça devient ça devient
bruantissime
elle a préféré faire le plus
un peu safe abscisse mesdames C3 il
patauge un peu là c'est pas trop ce
qu'il fait qu'il y a eu des deux bon
H5 elle sait où elle va et regardez-moi
ça la jeune Américaine regarde moi ça
regarde-moi ça regarde comment ça ici ça
marche ou pas ça marche pas c'est la
partie la jauge n'aime pas du tout
comment tu défends
alors
je peux t'échanger mais
attends attends attends
tu vois mais c'est vrai que d'un point
de vue d'un point de vue équipe quant à
Walid qui envoie G5
bon après
là on peut pas trop lui en vouloir c'est
ceux qui servent pas avec les blancs
avec les Blancs faut serrer un peu plus
sa vis là notre ami sourcil contre
contre theodoru là ça resolino pas
terrible et Louis ping avec les Blancs
il pouvait faire mieux quand même que ça
mais en tout cas qu'est-ce qu'elle fait
Alice pourquoi elle joue pas dans prince
3 là elle veut faire échec non elle a
fait chèque oh la vache vient de voir
peut-être qu'elle est F5 qu'il posait
problème
on va mourir moins bête
je mets là je vois pas mal au cou donc
je mets la variante alors
47 bonne chance courage 7 et là F3
c'était très compliqué en fait à voir
le coup du retour ok
0 et encore bref
intersidérale roi prend on va prendre à
trois et pas clair
on va voir
on va revenir au direct mais là ouais
c'est peut-être la fin des ah non non
mais là Alice vas-y hein allez allez
reprise dans l'équipe attention
carton rouge
il y a pas un point et l'eau qui est en
jeu on le rappelle peut-être les points
de chez.com mais c'est même pas sûr donc
bon là elle est obligé d'eux même pas ok
ok
notre ami
roi H7 va être joué parce que le
problème de Key prime F5 c'est quand on
reprend du cavalier et on a quand même
envie ça va être trop lent de faire tout
ça
quand même
au moins tout ça il a trouvé le hipping
intermédiaires histoire d'essayer de te
dévier la tour bon malheureusement tu as
l'air aussi des contrôles pourquoi
et du coup j'ai quand même qui avait des
problèmes trois qui peut arriver à un
moment donné parce que même si je suis
capable de prendre S3
j'ai tout refaire peut-être Adam mais
elle est un peu au chaud
j'ai pas l'occasion elle est beaucoup au
chaud
je je
t'aime pas de menace en fait c'est la
partie c'est la partie ils nous font
mentir
ok ok
et effectivement ouais ça arrive ça
arrive en équipe de France une accepté
qui fait perdre l'équipe de mémoire tout
à fait ça fait c'est c'est arrivé en
petit sera pas la personne
qui a fait ça les passionnés
retrouveront
alors dame priv F3 pion français 5 mais
effectivement quand on est assis à côté
et que
gagner bon bref ça met un peu le moral
c'est clair
il faut absolument la jouer c'est
compliqué
il faut absolument la jouer
B5
et Tour Eiffel jouer par
Louis ping
bon bah elle est foutue en fait mais bon
en même temps
[Musique]
en même temps elle a eu raison de
continuer qu'est-ce qui se passe avec
mon cadrage on m'a fait une blague
à moins que ça soit ouais
c'est ça aux Olympia de 2018 voilà c'est
facile à trouver maintenant du coup avec
malheureusement Étienne on a rejoint
médaille d'or
rétrospectivement en fait parce que bon
on savait pas qu'on joue à médaille d'or
jouer la Russie à la dernière ronde et
donc
en fait je vais le dire maintenant du
coup
on joue à la médaille d'or si on gagnait
2 et demi-heure et demi on gagnait on
gagnait le match et rétrospectivement et
le départage ont passé devant les USA ce
qui était pas trop mérité mais bon c'est
comme ça c'est une histoire de départage
bizarre et donc Étienne malheureusement
a perdu assez rapidement qu'on est Pau
maxime a fait nul contre kayaki et donc
je jouais cramique et Christian Bauer au
dernier je veux contre comment
s'appelle-t-il
et il avait une position c'est vrai ou
ça pouvait jouer moi ça jouait aussi et
donc du coup la nul elle faisait pas
perdre de match mais en tout cas elle a
empêché de gagner le match donc c'était
pour le coup c'était pas terrible quoi
c'est parti
chaude contre
par nul au final donc bon pas vraiment
de en fait ça change quand même ça
change sa façon de jouer aussi parce que
lui était pas sûr tu vois donc tout d'un
coup quand il y a une nul au quatrième
tu vois il y a deux pour eux donc le
jouer la gagne à fond parce qu'il me
faisait des trucs à la cramique tu vois
par contre il me décale tout ça c'est ça
c'est pas cool les gens de partir
et donc en fait ouais il a commencé à
serrer la vie il a tout échanger on a
fait nul donc
ce que je leur arrive à s'adapter tu
vois
et puis
ça je voulais ménages tu vois donc c'est
la dernière ronde
tu essayes de tu essayes de jeter un
coup d'œil sur tes camarades mais
toujours pour toujours pour l'équipe
donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe là
donc je sais pas trop quoi faire désolé
pour les cames mais il y a des gens qui
sont partis à part
que en fait il y avait plein de
résultats c'est ça il y a 10 à 6
à gagner déjà tu vois bon d'accord bon
ben j'arrive les caméras ok avec toutes
les histoires bon ben la remontada moi
j'y croyais un petit peu quand même
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on va aller
acheter
un fou
j'y croyais un petit peu à la
remontada on va aller je vais vous
enlever ces joueurs là parce que c'est
désagréable c'est mieux de rien à voir
et ouais il a gagné finalement il a maté
et qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans la
partie de veillez à gagner alors comment
les personnes à la tour
critique plus le choix par rapport à
l'enjeu c'est ça en fait ça me paraît
bizarre qui joue ça à ce moment-là du
match
mais après
il a fait une petite journée
par regardez-moi ça si roi eux en
encaisse ici sur water je suppose qu'on
fait j'ai trop avec ce petit fou qui est
très loin mais qui est très utile
monstrueux donc tourage trois fougères
et la tour à champ bon obligé de jouer
rien que par
sur le point esthétique en fait tu es
obligé de toi c'est quand même c'est dur
de refus c'est dur de de pas jouer à
coup pareil et en plus ça a l'air d'être
un très bon coup
j'ai un petit doute à chaque fois avec
Kevin
arrête ça m'empêcher de dormir pendant
trois jours
je chante de ces 10 dernières années
c'est la personne du tu sais de la salle
de jeux avec plus tard c'était à eux
contre qui t'a vraiment envie de gagner
c'est lui et voilà malheureusement
c'est mon grand
ouais c'est ça elle a fait elle a pas
très bien joué bon ok le reste c'est une
qualité de plus et théodoro qui s'est
refait mais un peu tard donc après 5
est-ce qu'il a fait notre ami
donc en fait Ding il est ça se trouve il
sera champion du monde il arrive canzer
tout seul il arrive à la réception de
l'hôtel et il demande pour Monsieur Ding
oui s'ils sont un petit truc il montre
ses bagues enfin tu vois c'est un peu il
a pas le
[Musique]
tu vois ce que je veux dire il se
comporte pas comme un champion du monde
bon après ça fait aussi son charme tu
vois
c'est il reste simple mais
faut quand même de l'aide je vois pas
j'espère qu'il va pas aller seul au
marché du monde surtout
j'imagine que les Chinois
quand même tu sais qu'il était seul au
candidat quand même
y aller tout seul au candidats
donc est-ce qu'il va aller tout seul au
mal de championnat du monde
moi je pense pas ça me semble
complètement parce que il y a plein de
trucs avec l'organisation et tout ça à
régler mais c'est pas c'est pas
complètement exclu en vrai
donc ça paraît donc peut-être qu'il y
avait qui travaille en français pas on
sait pas il y a toujours une certaine
opacité autour de ça et autour de la
préparation
des Chinois bon on verra tout ça en tout
cas on va faire un petit rappel ah ben
là ils m'ont mis il manque donc
on va vous mettre ça en direct ah ben
non complètement enlevé là
qui seront des salariés clients
à mon avis
à mon avis alors
Kevin dans le chat c'est vrai que si
là pour enfin c'est vrai qu'il y a Katia
c'est intéressant tu vois
est-ce qu'ils peuvent garder si si Kévin
est toujours là est-ce qu'ils peuvent
garder great shook
mvl Maëlle et Katia
parce que
et donc de 2007 ça te fait plus 300 là
ça fait - 200 et Maëlle ah ouais tu peux
garder Katia ah ouais on peut garder le
monde ah ouais bien sûr
cette règle avoir une féminine à 2550
on va rappeler le format oui donc voilà
ça fait ça fait cinq jours que
j'explique le format j'ai toujours rien
compris mais c'est très très gros c'est
qui là pour le coup
et les Chinois qui sont très bon moi
pour l'instant les Indiens du premier
jour les Chinois les chaises bras
évidemment avec Magnus ça peut être
aussi du très lourd on a vu aussi ben
stream évidemment très impressionnant et
aussi leurs adversaires en fait parce
que les adversaires étaient très bon en
fait
c'était un très très gros match c'était
deux équipes qui sont qui sont favorites
pour se qualifier dans le dans les
derniers 8 ça c'est sûr
en tout cas la prise par par le petit
Français Kevin
parce que en fait tu vois le match c'est
juste c'est ça pourrait être quasiment
de finale en fait
ça peut être une fille et il y a aussi
évidemment j'allais oublier les
Américains avec Nakamura l'équipe de
Nakamura et les Gotham Knights avec
nakay hier bon il a fait une
il a fait une première partie
bon qui reste mais il fera pas ça
à chaque fois ça c'est sûr Naka les
Kwang qui est pas manchot qui m'aime
très très bon surtout dans ces trucs
rapides ils avaient un jeune wood war là
qui était bon aussi et
une féminine qui je me rappelle plus qui
c'était mais elle tenait la route très
largement
je sais plus ils avaient une demi carte
encore je crois
c'est pas mais bon en fait c'est
assimilé donc c'est pareil donc on va
avoir ce match normalement ça commence à
19h ou pas ou ça dure en
retarder
tu devrais savoir dans le zoom peut-être
si tu as des joueurs qui arrivent ah
ouais tu as raison s'ils sont là c'est
que ça va commencer
s'ils sont pas là alors attends où
est-ce que j'ai le zoom
la page pour eux il y a en tout cas
oui mais elle est très dangereuse mal
m'avait déchiré sur tescom on avait fait
un petit match
et ouais
d'accord ah bah oui donc ça veut dire
que oui
et
dans la liste
bon les jours ce n'est pas là dans le
zoom je crois elle doit être pure que je
crois non bulgare
[Musique]
il y a une vidéo de lui il y a un
Panther Blitz qu'il avait fait avec
Carsen et je pense que tu vas voir
là-bas je sais plus s'il l'a vu
mais hyper impressionnante quoi en tout
cas il a tout envoyé et je sais plus ce
qui s'est passé dans cette partie parce
que je crois qu'à la fin du flag d'un
côté ou de l'autre me demande s'il a pas
gagné 45 mais je sais plus c'était
c'était sur ces jours à la fin en Bullet
on sait qu'il est hyper dangereux hein
moins dangereux sur la globalité mais
bon
il peut te faire quatre sur quatre ça
c'est certitude alors après c'est pas
aucune garantie évidemment mais si un
jour de forme il peut il peut faire très
très mal
il peut faire donc
faut voir faut voir évidemment mais ça
va être passionnant à suivre on rappelle
c'est là première journée c'est le
dernier match de la première journée
donc rien n'est joué personne éliminé
personne est champion on joue pour se
qualifier pour les quarts de finale on
joue ça sur plusieurs semaines c'est un
championnat au long cours
avec je crois trois éliminés au bout de
trois semaines c'est pas mal leur
système quand même les trois derniers
qui sont éliminés et après deux et après
3 et on définit comme ça les quarts de
finalistes et je crois que même
je suis pas sûr mais ça se joue en
hybride peut-être les quarts de finale
avec en mode tu joues
tu joues sur un ordinateur mais tu joues
dans la même pièce
ok d'accord si on a encore enfin watch
Party à Paris ça va être ouf donc c'est
pas sur place
ah ben d'accord ben on ira au watch
party alors ouais je suis parti pour Jo
faut faire ça en même temps que les JO
moi je suis très chaud sur les JO
j'attends les JO de pied ferme ça sera
les 20 avant les JO
ces deux mises sur place d'accord ah et
quart de finale donc ça peut être
d'accord demi sur place aucun intérêt
donc là c'est où c'est du coup ça génial
ça
pue San Francisco cette histoire ce
serait ouf ouais mais tu vois c'est
super
[Musique]
qui sont qui sont pro hein
Joséphine qui banaka bravo mais déjà
faut le jouer Naka je veux dire combien
de joueurs à 2300 on
cette expérience là de jouer de jouer de
jouer contre Naka et évidemment de le
battre c'est la c'est le gâteau c'est la
cerise enfin comme vous voulez mais en
tout cas voilà ça donne une expérience
folle à des joueurs et Maëlle je suis
sûr qu'il est il est ravi c'est un jeune
c'est un jeune qui a plein de talents et
donc il va jouer des bah il va
certainement rejouer Carlson à un moment
ou un autre fois
la demi à Paris
ouais alors faut voir
mais il a fait très très bon
il est très bon rapide c'est sûr mais il
est spécialement moi je peux me faire
adopter contre Maëlle ambulette je pense
que je suis favoré ouais
c'est à dire que je perds en fait c'est
comme si je jouais en
si tu veux je rends je perds 30 secondes
je pense au mouvement de
pièces dans les 30 premiers coups sinon
tu as perdu quoi c'est ça et comme quand
même il bouge les pièces très
correctement c'est
tout perdre quoi
et c'est pour ça que j'ai pas joué j'ai
pas joué beaucoup contre
particulièrement de perdre toutes les
parties d'affilée
alors est-ce que ça commence ou pas en
tout cas ils sont pas dans le col nos
amis t'as pas encore de non j'ai
personne
ou pas
moi j'ai rien encore il y a pas de
message de
alors c'est moi qui ai raté
quand même donc ça devrait pas tarder en
tout cas rester on a un très beau match
entre on va peut-être rappeler le la
fiche on l'a pas remonté mais
regardez-moi ça c'est quand même pas mal
avec California unicorne ils peuvent
être pas mauvais dangereux Robson Mayer
et Sabina fois il sort qui est
clairement sous classé
ils sont favoris je pense quand même ah
remarque
il nous manque l'info de Danet Var mais
a priori comme tu as dit avec son nom et
son allô ça me dit quelque chose mais là
je peux pas te dire
mais
ouais
mon avis il doit être bon rapide mais
bon après on va oui première partie
intéressante contre girls Myers
qui bon lui au moins on sait ce qui va
on sait les résultats qui va faire à peu
près tu vois gang Meyer
soit il va faire moins 50%
voir soit il fait soit il fait deux et
demi soit trois voilà c'est ça c'est son
c'est son score
donc ce que ça donne
sa carrière
qui est de 150
je sais pas ce qui donne en rapide mais
je sais que c'est un jeune
on va assister un gros match ça c'est
sûr
mais à quelle heure ça c'est la c'est la
deuxième question on en sait trop rien
[Musique]
on va voir
et ce qui est marrant c'est une chose
soit plus de
demander et il y a trop de monde dans ce
mois ça me fait peur
ce cela il y a trop de monde
je parle pas
[Musique]
qui a 3000 et longs ambulettes
3000 02
et donc ok ouais
du coup oui bon ils sont dangereux en
fait d'accord
petites équipes il y a pas de petites
équipes là déjà faut se qualifier je
crois pour enfin il y a une division 2
quoi en fait tu vois il y a un truc de
pour se qualifier d'une année sur
l'autre et tout ça ouais il y a pas de
petites équipes
après on sent il y a quand même des
équipes au dessus
de la citer les cinq six équipes étaient
au-dessus
2007 c'est des petits 2007 quoi t'as pas
de mvl ou de
la cas ou de saut de genre comme ça quoi
exactement et attention car wanna je
crois qu'il peut il est sur la liste de
Saint-Louis il a pas joué cette fois
mais il pourrait il pourrait rentrer
donc là ils ont perdu peut-être que il
faut faire il faut faire un prêt Fabi là
pour le coup ouais
[Musique]
il pourrait peut-être qui en plus
donc peut-être que ils peuvent
s'arranger remarque ça change rien
alors c'est quoi la question je sais pas
moi tous les
ca veut dire bien jouer
je sais pas pour un supercherie
je sais pas moi je trouve qu'on joue
tous mal mais les parties de Magnus avec
stockfish tu vas rigoler
donc à partir de 3600 aujourd'hui on
commence à faire moins de faute j'ai
l'impression voilà alpha zero a l'air de
jouer pas mal quand même donc mais sinon
objectivement on joue tous assez mal
quand tu regardes les ordis même Magnus
de 1850 contre stockfish
le match tournerait assez court donc on
fait tous plein d'erreurs donc
finalement faut y croire
faut pas se laisser impressionner par le
hello ou par le alors la vue d'ailleurs
on a qu'à moi il a perdu contre quand
Joséphine ainaman donc tout est possible
dans la vie et aux échecs
après les parties d'ordi et moi je
regarde de temps en temps alors c'est un
truc de geek sur twitch TC excellent
chaîne bon on n'est pas nombreux mais tu
auras les parties d'ordi quand tu as des
matchs en 100 parties de stock Fisher tu
sais moi j'ai une petite fenêtre ouverte
et tu entends le petit bip calecou a été
joué ici c'est génial je vous conseille
allez-y vous mettez ça en fond alors
c'est un truc
mais non mais en fait tu n'auras pas
tout le temps tu vois parce que quand a
été joué mais c'est assez je t'assure
les coups jouer ils sont surprenant
alors moi j'espère évidemment
apprendre de ça mais malheureusement je
crois pas que j'apprenne beaucoup mais
juste pour le kiffe juste pour tu vois
de voir les coups jouer et à chaque fois
tu es là tu dis ah ouais pas mal pas mal
donc voilà allez voir
si ça vous intéresse
ouais la chaîne est cool oui mais les
parties sont incompréhensibles oui oui
oui mais c'est ça c'est justement ça la
pointe du truc et après non mais il te
met les lignes il te met les lignes et
pourquoi il les a joué donc tu peux plus
ou moins comprendre le raisonnement mais
c'est vrai que les parties sont derrière
effectivement et comment comment
expliquer il y a quand des taux dans le
chat de cette chaîne non mais en fait
c'est ça c'est comme si tu demandes en
fait c'est comme si tu demandes à 1600
d'expliquer de une partie entre deux
entre deux 200600 moi si vous me donnez
expliquer les parties entre 3600 bah j'y
comprends rien en fait c'est normal
c'est voilà
c'est ça qui est qui est qui est
passionnant quoi finalement qui est un
peu enfin alors je sais pas mes journées
vous inquiétez pas mais en tout cas je
sais pas je trouve ça marrant quoi je
trouve que c'est ça ressemble plus à un
jeu vidéo que des échecs mais c'est
c'est assez intéressant
mais le problème pourquoi d'ailleurs
pourquoi les joueurs ne jouent pas
contre l'ordi pour s'entraîner mieux
comprendre les positions mais le
problème c'est qu'on prend on comprend
pas tout ce qui fait leur dit
donc ça en fait c'est dur de l'assimiler
si on comprend pas
tcec notoriage j'ai envoyé tout le monde
vers chez
TC et aussi internet il y a une chaîne
twitch ils ont lancé une chaîne twitch
qui a succès moderne
alors ça a commencé ou pas
non tu en es où toi dans tes dans tes
est-ce que les gens arrivent
attends je vais demander à
je
comprends pas
je comprends pas
je vais essayer de lui envoyer un
message en privé je suis pas parce que
si ça déjà commencé on a l'air bête
non non
non mais oui oui
c'est sûr enfin je
[Musique]
19h tous les jours on a le je vais vous
le mettre
le sketch
alors du coup on est au Kevin en fait
ouais non j'avais pas compris que sur le
texcom on peut régler par par ronde et
moi j'étais dans la ronde 5 en fait on
va dire que ça c'est la ronde un bref je
me suis compris et c'est
attends attends salut hein
alors là je suis en galère
là parce que je les ai au mauvais
endroit enfin je sais même pas qui est
qui en fait je raconte pas le temps
H3 normalement qu'on joue avec les
Blancs
donc ce cas ici qui est assez
provocateur pour le mois de décembre
une sorte de nimesovic voilà ou à une
moderne où on perd le temps mais c'est
vrai que les Blancs jouaient des cinq
donc ça ça fait du jeu après excessif
bon effectivement c'est pour
déséquilibrer le tout c'est vraiment ça
l'idéal ok c'est trois roues
il y avait une période partie contre moi
qui était assez épique oui il m'a fait
non mais en fait je le connais parce
qu'il m'a fait ça en Magnus première
partie il m'a fait ça kf6 E5
ans plus tard on joue aux grandes
chaises donc moi je fais le type qui
comprend pas je fais des 5 à tuer le sac
c'est pas clair et tout ça c'est très
bien qu'il va jeter des V8 donc je fais
Kaly F3 et là il me joue le coup qui me
tue il me joue cavalier abscisse et là
quand même bon la fierté la fierté
au-dessus de tout
donc des cinq et B8 et c'est 3D 6
le 4 G6 et voilà on est retombé dans ce
qu'ils ont en ce moment donc voilà où
j'ai joué là du coup la fierté là
j'étais chaud j'ai fait des fous trois
dames des deux j'essaie de le mater
j'avais une dame de plus j'avais une
j'étais je faisais dame dans cette
partie j'étais à plus plus douce et j'ai
perdu mais bon
marrant à la faille il a comme
d'habitude donc la magie car c'est
niènes et donc A3 à 6 ouais ben ça c'est
connu en fait
c'est évident mais
ça joue alors attends je vais essayer de
voir s'ils sont là moi je vois pas les
alors Dame des deux on peut espérer
peut-être pour moi pour moi il y a pas
de caméra
pas de caméra je vais regarder sur sur
la chaîne internationale
[Rires]
je sais pas pourquoi ben non il y a pas
de caméra chez eux il y a pas de caméra
ah ben on est aussi bon que et oui
on est chez naroline Ski et
il y a pas de caméra ça veut dire que il
y a un problème avec les caméras quand
même ils ont ils sont combien à la
production
mais très bien Dame des deux alors on va
voir le ça c'est la première partie on a
aussi à l'échiquier 2 dès qu'on a la
caméra on vous le dit on a Guillaume
Mayer avec les Blancs qui fait son son
retire qui pleuve qu'il neige ou qu'ils
ventent il fait des répit et on tombe
dans une dans une catalane qu'on a vu
plein ces derniers jours un peu hacker
ces trois mais il veut pas prendre et on
joue à 5 ouais on prend de l'espace bah
ça c'est l'influence donc là on
demandait il y avait une question sur
les ordinateurs ça c'est l'influence de
lilas qui joue comme ça des A5 H5 ou
h4a4 avec les Blancs qui prend l'espace
en fait et qui souvent peut sortir les
tours aussi par là mais voilà on a
appris que c'était c'était important de
faire ça
donc on copie bête
ça prend des cases B6 fois 6
on sait jamais ça peut venir ça serait
une surprise
qui est des deux qui est BD
bon là normalement on est tenté de faire
le 4
24 maintenant
c'est pas encore où tu mets le four
G5 F4 plus d'options après 4 peut-être
il faut calculer un petit peu je suppose
puis on prend
esprit de 5 peut-être un peu comme ça
ouais ou alors E5 aussi il faut calculer
mais bon ça a pas l'air trop marcher
attention à la maison est solide donc il
va il va vérifier ce genre de choses
donc peut-être fou B2 d'abord mais vous
B2 autorise B5 aussi donc ça c'est une
autre idée pour pour essayer de faire B4
et retarder un petit peu le coup le 4
du coup le pion E4 souvent en prise
ouais mais remarque là en fait non
en fait tu défends beaucoup de fois donc
tu peux commencer par fou B2 on feeling
moi pour pas avoir d'histoire je jouais
tous les deux quand même
[Musique]
avec prise prise 5 et très bon pour les
Noirs
en fait par contre on peut prendre du
cavalier on peut être tenté de prendre
du cavalier le 4 DC a été joué et là il
va certainement reprendre du cavalier
prends du cavalier comment ce qu'on joue
ici
quel coup
P5
sur
C5 on a des 5
types
de fruits B5 du coup tu gardes 5
mais je mets mon fou sur une bonne
diagonale
parce que j'ai je décide déjà
ça devient concret ça devient concret
mais bon on va voir on va voir ce qu'il
va faire allez on fait un petit tour des
stades allez et tu me dis quand ils ont
mis les caméras sur le attends
non mais là je peux pas les avoir
non j'ai aucune caméra bon désolé mais
là
si sur le truc YouTube ils ont pas les
caméras je peux rien faire
alors on acht
jeunes joueurs d'origine polonaise
qui a les Noirs contre danache Var le
fameux
avec les Blancs bon
bah il a réussi son ouverture c'est à
peu près équilibré c'est équilibré tu as
l'impression blanche légère
mais les pièces sont un peu moins bien
placées Smart un peu dessus le mb8 tout
ça mais ok rien d'alarmant ouais on est
complètement d'accord et aller au
dernier échec qui est on a chewbalova
donc
face à hey Robson
c'était une fille qui aimait beaucoup
tout balancé
direct au bout de 5 coups c'est vérifié
qui existe donc elle a rien inventé mais
c'est hyper intéressant et fous des
trois et on se développe rapidement
hyper intéressant ce truc là
artificielle qui donne des pions un
petit peu qui s'est remis qui a remis ça
là au goût du jour pour un jeu de pièces
plus fluide et voilà clairement bon ben
je vous garantie
elle veut faire
bon je fais une pièce sur une grossesse
en tout cas là ouais en tout cas elle
est partie pour la sacrifier un pion
donc ouais faut bien un pseudo c'est une
idée il y a aussi H4 j'aime bien H4 H4
qui conjugue un peu deux idées la
première c'est de faire cavalier 5 pour
pour bataquer H7 et placer la dame etc
et la deuxième c'est éventuellement H4
H5 H6 qui est aussi une idée qu'on peut
avoir dans cette position elle fait à
trois pourquoi elle fait à 3 parce que
elle avait les BK arrive
ça a pas traîné ou alors H4 d'abord on a
le temps en fait parce que il met du
temps à être valorisé finalement ce pur
alors il est là on est content qu'il
soit là évidemment attention que ces
quatre cavaliers c'est 5 quand même peut
vite finir échanger des pièces tu me
donnes des cases aussi hein attention
leur histoire alors c'est pas très grave
parce que tu as encore du jeu mais tu
m'as un peu finalement dévié de de mon
but initial
et j'arrive à avoir une attaque assez
intéressante là je pense que d'ici une
heure ou deux tu es tu étais fan de
cheval auval
est déjà là
tu voulais attendre mais même là en fait
je peux le faire direct peut-être pour
jouer sur le vis-à-vis et prendre des
cartes j'ai toujours pensé 6 je prends
la paire de fou et puis on sait et puis
on Descartes qui pourraient être une
cible plus tard
moi j'aime bien les positions un peu
avec initiative comme ça pour le blanc
donc c'est vrai que j'aime bien ça
ah j'ai entendu un bruit un bruit
l'ancienne collègue de chaise 24 alors
voilà
[Musique]
alors donc du coup il y a eu ces quatre
de jouer
par RER Robson et donc on va peut-être
avoir droit à cavaler des cartes du coup
ces quatre jouets paraît Robson ici ou
tu vas voir
on peut aller voir des
trucs qui ont bougé et on voit dernier
cheval qui m'est pression franchement
talent tout à l'heure mais là il est il
est il est pas mal hein une grosse
pression
surprenant
j'ai dû alors je sais pas j'ai pas mal
de coups intéressants mais je peux pas
bouger avec les dents en fait c'est une
torture gros client ce dernier je vais
apparemment la première partie après
je vais lui mettre la pression comme ça
[Musique]
il y a eu cette structure dont on
parlait il a pris ouais d'accord il
donne le fou
ok
j'aime bien
qu'il veut pas perdre notre gaz noir
et du coup la petite pousse c'est ça
tu peux pas
à laisser 5 avril 17 mais bon ça a très
très loin quand même je pense
très très lent cette histoire
ouais ouais mais moi j'aimais pas du
tout qui avait le 4 là ça me faisait
peur alors que j'ai quatre petites
tactiques si on fait dame blanche
voilà ça crée la dame
pour le matin F2 esthétique on pourrait
prendre la dame aussi si on n'est pas un
artiste pour la dame alors
du coup
j'avais pas vu
le problème c'est que je ferme
je ferme tout il se passerait au passage
puis au pire au pire du pire je
t'échange tout et puis j'ai un pion de
plus j'ai un Caval et hâte un cavalier
aux fraises
ça c'est une certitude évidemment qui
connaît bien ces petits systèmes allez
on va voir peut-être je suis valova pour
avoir
parce que tu peux faire d'autre
même B prend sa carte B prend ses câble
j'aurais dû tourner 4 derrière ça pas du
tout qui avait il a joué ces trois
excuse-moi j'étais encore dans cette
histoire de caméra je crois que je vais
abandonner dans dans un instant parce
que j'ai l'impression que vanner
elle a juste elle en galère d'Internet
comme ça c'est pas il y a un truc
elle répond pas sur ce lac les trucs
sont off bon ça sent mauvais la personne
qui nous qui nous envoyait les caméras
malheureusement petit problème
d'internet j'ai l'impression
c'est pas son genre
donc
B3 C3 comment on fait pour alors moi
c'est ouais c'est tout moi ça moi je
vous dis comment on fait pour récupérer
espion voir ce qu'elle joue au valova
non mais reste à toi bien joué quoi
alors moi il y a plusieurs coups qui ce
que j'aime bien vas-y le premier coup
c'est H4
[Rires]
qui arrive qu'il faut regarder quand
même ouais
même si ça marchera jamais
j'adore le j'adore le concept c'est on
va les regarder bon on sait que ça
marche pas mais on les regarde quand
même quoi c'est le c'est le plaisir
c'est le plaisir des échecs c'est beau
en fait bon c'est un style c'est un
style assez chaud et c'est que en tant
qu'amateur c'est c'est toujours cool de
voir d'attaque un peu comme ça tu vois
et en partie longue elle fait pareil je
dis en commentaire
on a commenté la Coupe d'Europe donc
c'était en anglais avec avec vitre sur
chaise 24 et Chupa Laura tous les jours
on allait voir parce qu'on sait quand tu
sais il y a un moment en plus partie
longue tu as toujours un petit peu
qui joue attends on va voir sa partie et
puis
tu es sûr tu as c'est bon c'est bon pour
le prochain quart d'heure tu es tu as
des trucs à raconter il y a du contenu
H6 et la devine ce qu'elle a joué encore
une fois
malheureusement elle a un fou angélique
G4
[Musique]
très positionnel B4 non je plaisante
elle a joué tout des 4 pour faire pour
ramener encore une tour et dans un style
tour C8 Dame des trois joué par cheval
vas-y je te fais passer d'abord la tour
et maintenant je sais pas ce qu'elle
fait moi je comprends rien je devine
jamais un coup ma gueule
ça fait vraiment une menace c'est génial
peut-être du coup peut-être que B4 x 2
va être recyclé est-ce que tu es là bon
j'ai pas eu tous mes quatre mais
ça peut être une idée sur le long terme
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire à part ça
on a trouvé le
présenter en fait
voilà c'est ça c'est le coup de foudre
chez qui voilà
le reste nous regarde pas mais en tout
cas le coup de fouiller un coup de
foudre ok en direct
[Musique]
c'est un coup qui qui a été dans sa
reine Jean même maintenant
tour G4 quand même
est-ce qu'on récupère alors moi
évidemment je propose toujours le coup
le coup à côté le coup de l'épicerie qui
récupère un pion je pense que c'est
impossible
qui est vite 5 mais il y a peut-être du
Fou au 4 un jour pas si c'est l'idée ou
pas essayer de changer c'est fou là
ouais aussi
[Musique]
il est bloqué
dur ciel bleu je parlais de coup de
foudre chez killer on a le droit il y a
des gens comme ça on adore le style
moi c'est Magnus voilà j'adore son style
donc
tout ça hyper technique à tout échanger
toute la journée
voilà bon remarque on est nombreux
alors ton français 3 qu'est-ce qui se
passe sur
G4 n'est peut-être toujours pas un coup
malheureusement
cinq jouets par Hobson il paye pour voir
là
on prend pas trop quand même ce qu'on
veut faire ici
donc
moi je connais pas la caméra alors moi
c'est la caméra de cheval au bas non je
l'avais sur
l'autre sur l'autre site non mais là il
y a un vrai non non mais on a un
problème de caméra de toute façon
malheureusement
je suis désolé mais
[Musique]
non non mais elle est complètement
on va voir les caméras pour la pour la
deuxième partie ok cool promesse de
texte
qui s'apparente à une promesse de gascon
et un partout qui a gagné contre sabenas
friends on s'y attendait Mayer a gagné
on s'y attendait aussi
un partout et on va avoir
qu'est-ce qui va se passer dans prime
de plus Ray Robson on a une dernière
partie entre schwarch qui se fait visser
qui a 5 secondes contre notre ami indien
pour cette première pour s'offrir un
match ouais si
Robson gagne contre chevalova ouais il a
une pièce de plus Robson pour deux pions
tu me diras il y a un peu de jeu encore
mais bon
c'est la malle au temps elle a 38
secondes face à une minute
et ouais ça l'Arthur quand même pour le
blanc ici mais bon il y a toujours un
peu de jeu il y a toujours un peu de jeu
il y a deux pions il y a la paire de fou
écoute c'est pas si mal c'est pas si mal
tout ça c'est pas encore totalement fini
donc on prend son temps
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait là du coup
trouver un coup pour les noirs
un coup qui ne donne pas de jeu que fait
car scène ici
dame à 8 tours
je crois qu'on peut même faire tourner
et j'encaisse et si tu veux
je suis très content donc j'aime
beaucoup j'aime beaucoup son coup pardon
excuse-moi
de tout savoir quand on a une pièce de
plus on rencontre matériel d'avance et
pas en échange de pièces tout à fait on
prend pas la tête on échange des pièces
pour éviter le contre le jeu adverse
dans des conditions
raisonnables
pétrin juste pour échanger une pièce
mais de manière générale si on peut
changer des pièces et enlever le
contrôle d'adversaire jackpot
pas de Gaston Gaston
en fait 3
en tout cas
ça va être
ça va être le cirque alors
c'est le cirque
contrer oui ça marche pas toi à chaque
fois ces attaques en fait surtout que ça
marche pas trop contre les joueurs de ce
niveau là quoi c'est ça en fait est-ce
que son style il est hyper intéressant
moi j'aime bien
tu avais compris
là
en fait
et bon la nuit sera pas prise non il y a
peu de temps la pendule
on va voir
ici
je cherche
il a fait nul ok après une grosse
souffrance énorme souffrance en
souffrance
ah mais tu vois bonne histoire c'est le
numéro 3 et
[Musique]
là
on les connaît tous un peu
meilleur Robson c'est
du lourd
et en plus sur internet
tu vois enfin meilleur il est présent
dans tous les tournois qu'online c'est
un habitué beaucoup de liberté
pour la deuxième
j'ai besoin d'un petit break après
toutes ces émotions pour le caméra
avant le deuxième avant la deuxième
partie c'est le début et demi un match
qui s'annonce passionnant là pour le
coup parce que non pas mal de choses et
puis ça regroupe pas mal c'est vrai
quand on voit les les affiches on voit
on la Robson qui a un joueur qui aime
bien attaquer
et puis on a aussi souvent lova qui aime
bien attaquer enfin moi j'aime c'est un
match franchement je me régale ça va
être beau
merci de nous suivre rester avec nous et
la suite du match tout de suite ciao
ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez c'est parti et tu vas me dire
alors
quand est-ce que ça recommence mais tu
vas me dire qu'elle est blanche qu'elle
est noire on va voir le joueur sur mon
truc numéro 7 alors ça c'est des hack
est-ce qu'il est blanc
ok
alors qu'il y a des blancs donc Rondo 2
on a des blancs contre meilleur super tu
m'as mis
je vois la priorité
[Musique]
je sais pas qui c'est
le 4 chez qui
et Maya il a il a quoi il est blanc
meilleur
noir noir
incroyable
ce qui est en train de se passer là j'ai
une chance pour l'instant absolument
honteuse
alors le prochain que j'ai sur la liste
c'est son livre
il est blanc
est-ce que sa vida foyers est blanc
un moment donné
elle peut avoir tout juste elle est
noire contre lui
ok pas grave on va faire coulisser notre
ami
non
et la dernière ça sera
alors le dernier ce sera du coup
Darius verte contre Polina cheval blanc
tout à fait
il est là
je pense
voilà
du coup alors
est-ce qu'on sait quand ça commence moi
j'ai pas encore les parties qui
s'affichent
tout à l'heure j'avais un petit bug
alors là ça la revente deux du coup
et
[Musique]
California unicornes j'ai la partie de
DAC qui commence à l'instant des 4 E6
cavaliers F3
cavalier 6 C4
pour le tour
non plus 4 c'est Robson
des hack
qui est là voilà
gentiment
je descends
mais si fouger de fou baisser de petits
rock
donc maintenant joue pour le pour
l'Uruguay d'ailleurs c'est vrai je crois
que ça peut paraître
étrangeait
mais il parle plein de langues je crois
qu'il parle français il parle très
français
il parle tout je crois
un message une fois où je je
devantais pas c'est
donc
il donne la paire de fou mais il espère
égaliser petit à petit il va connaître
peut-être cavalier 7 ici pour venir
chasser la dame
c'est pas possible
c'est un plan possible j'imagine mal
girl ne pas connaître en peut jouer
aussi tour C8 pour faire cavalier A5 et
menacer
oui parce que je peux pas jouer
non je pensais un truc mais le tour
c'est vite joué
pas très étonnant
avec un P4 peut-être pour je suis
B25 je crois madame défonce
tu as pris de l'espace écoute c'est
c'est raisonnable il faut bien la mettre
quelque part la damage 4N drôle de tête
c'est vrai mais en tout cas ça prend
deux coups pour
pour la faire bouger et finalement le
cavalier qui se replace pas en
pas très bien placé donc c'est un coup
malin et en plus on menace parfois des
fougères 6 qui sont intéressants
d'ailleurs faut j'ai cinq étangs ici
clairement il a joué P4 ton coup
des stades là je vois que toutes les
parties ont commencé donc on a livaich
contre
Sabina foyers
ils sont mais je vais les retrouver ne
vous inquiétez pas
donc les Belges qui fait une
[Musique]
livage
avec une différence de classement et
l'eau pas forcément très passif
alors ça ça joue ça peut jouer des tours
attention et on voit le fameux calabrais
que tu as rappelé tout à l'heure là il
menaçait
presque possible
ça manque de pièces ça manque d'une
pièce en attaque
une pièce parce que au final si tu
achète était possible ça pourrait
éventuellement être possible mais tu
reprends
un moment donné donc
mais bon et puis on descend quand même
un peu en souffrance quand même c'est un
césarienne
aussi permet de sortir sur vous quand
même une française
une fois qu'on a fait exactement
de recycler tout ça il fait le 4 c'est
vrai que le pion aussi c'est en prise
logique le 4 en plus après 6 et ben tu
as quand même affaibli les cases
blanches
donc du coup ouvrir les 15 branches ici
est assez
logique prise ca va les prendre cavaler
ses 5 sont une belle casserole dans sa 5
très logique
et donc on a danachevard les deux
derniers contre irobson qu'on va
retrouver tout de suite Danette Var face
à rail
que je vois pas du coup et donc
ça veut dire
on rappelle
quand même aux gens qu'on n'est pas
voilà il y a pas de évidemment le choix
anglais il y a des producteurs
ce qui fait quand même une différence
c'est qu'ils ont les caméras un peu plus
vite mais bon
c'est pas en fait ceux qui font le
stream si tu voulais enfin ceux qui
commentent ils ont pas la technique à
faire exactement nous on fait tout et du
coup c'est pas la même
c'est pas la même
n'importe quoi en plus avec la fatigue
donc qu'est-ce qui se passe dans cette
partie c'est une sorte de ça marroxy
dragon accéléré
c'est une sorte vraiment accéléré avec
du coup A4 qui vient d'être joué à 4 qui
empêche un petit peu l'équipe P4 enfin
de garantir un peu ces idées de B4 qui
est aussi un cadre à 5 pour un cavalier
Winda
qu'est-ce qu'on joue ici à 4
alors généralement cette position comme
vraiment de sidérée marozzi à ce
niveau-là c'est quand même dur pour les
pour les noirs
alors je le sais parce que je vais quand
même je pense très longtemps ça et
contre les joueurs expérimentés avec
quand même pas mal de mal avec les
et après j'ai eu des bons résultats
quand même à chaque fois sur
avec ça mais c'est vrai que
c'est pas toujours une partie de plaisir
tout à fait
prise en passant
et maintenant comment est-ce qu'on joue
c'est pas facile les noirs
en E6 D4 mais bon je vois pas trop
comment il va faire parce qu'après après
après B4 blanc
comment tu joues ton espace c'est ça le
truc
parce que
qui veut jouer le cavalier c'est 600 E5
pour taper sur le pion C4 et avec le fou
qui tape sur le dessin peut-être que
c'est ce qui veut faire c'est ça
c'est vrai que ça fait bien un petit peu
la structure de jouer B4 voilà B4
c'est qu'on gagne de l'espace avec un
gain de temps etc c'est cool mais dans
le côté quand vous bougez un peu comme
ça pensez aussi au pire à côté au casque
vous donnez et le pion s'éclate qui
tient refait parce qu'il est le plus
fort tu sais par le pion c'est vrai que
ça peut poser problème ça peut être un
établissement
donc B4 cavalu aussi
faut être sûr de B4 en fait
ici B4 c'est pas forcément
le coup le plus safe peut-être qu'on
pourrait préparer un peu plus peut-être
faire ton RC1 cavaler des cartes d'abord
un truc comme ça et après voir ce qui se
passe mais béclate ça peut être des fois
un peu
un peu un peu prématuré un peu un peu
trop vite
tout à fait que tout à fait qu'est-ce
que je veux pas avec un torse
de forcer à t'organiser un petit peu je
reprends ces cinq c'est une menace voilà
comme tu peux la montrer avec un
professeur donc ça peut aller vite ce
genre d'histoire
bien un problème quand même d'espace tu
vois la dame noire on sait pas où la
mettre
j'ai pas beaucoup de d'espace c'est très
dur pour pour les Noirs franchement ok
alors
ta
favoriais pas mais ça c'est pas
allez ou par contre je suis de la
production noire
alors
Darius j'avais une anecdote avec lui
toi de ma vie tu sais c'était une année
ou en fait il y avait bon c'était il y a
peut-être trois ans un truc comme ça ou
4 ans et le gagnant du tatou tu faisais
et ben affronter Carlsen pour le
c'était le
comment s'appelle le speechess ah oui
d'accord ok et en fait du coup bah j'ai
fait trop de ma vie et j'avais donc il y
a combien de monde
[Musique]
et j'ai donc senti j'avais
j'avais 8 je sais plus j'étais en
embuscade en fait oui j'ai fait une fois
top 10 et ça se tourner là et en fait
j'étais en l'embuscade pour pour la
première place il y avait un joueur je
sais plus que c'était je crois que
c'était crié oriente
qui avait 8 ans et demi et tout le monde
avait 8 et je me suis dit si je
le vois en fait je peux gagner quoi et
bon j'imagine si je vous garantis mais
qu'en plus c'est n'importe quoi
et elle fait trois heures trois heures
qu'on était en scène tu passes pas un
bon quart d'heure même si bon j'aurais
kiffé mais voilà et du coup j'espère
qu'on se verte
et j'ai une pièce nette de plus il m'a
joué à un truc complètement stupide
c'était une variante un peu je sais plus
je crois que c'était c'était un B3 foulé
2 il m'a donné une pièce en un coup
alors je sais plus comment c'était moi
c'était un truc bizarre c'est une pièce
nette de plus j'ai beaucoup de temps
d'avancé à la pendule et j'ai commencé à
trembler j'ai fait n'importe quoi chaque
coup que je faisais c'est du coup plus
nuls les uns après les autres et j'ai
perdu la partie alors j'avais
du coup finalement non non non
parce qu'en fait les grandes a gagné et
après
c'est trop dur pourtant
il est tellement reçu c'était
du coup j'avais une pièce nette d'avance
d'ailleurs je me demande je me demande
si je l'avais pas s'il avait pas
mis la pièce tellement c'était je sais
plus mais c'était ridicule la partie
c'est un niveau mais là c'est c'est pas
mal ce qui nous fait quand tu sois là
je te dis qu'elle normalement
c'est une chose active donc du coup
quand vous voulez prendre des jours
actif comme ça il faut empêcher de
les empêcher de de s'activer de jouer
des positions tactiques et du coup ce
qui fait c'est parfait il joue
positionner il prend les cases
et en fait elle se retrouve un peu
étouffée elle arrive pas à
elle arrive pas à balancer les pions
là c'est quand même alors voilà un petit
peu il faut essayer quand même et c'est
dur parce que même si tu fais quoi comme
ça en fait cavalier il va être un
déblojable
tu peux même pas le manger j'ai tout
reprend et c'est pire
et là on peut imaginer mettre un petit
je sais pas sur le long terme mettre le
fond en G2
[Musique]
tu as pas besoin de donner
du contre-jour après effectivement un
petit coup de fouet j'ai trois fous j'ai
deux ça serait certainement très
raisonnable mais ça donnerait un petit
truc alors évidemment c'est pas grand
chose
d'avoir un peu de contrôle
ok bon ben une partie triste pour cheval
voilà qui propose un échange oui et se
rétablit à structure ça c'est bien vu
marche pas mais cavaliers 7 donc on
prend pas mais on fait roi fuite et sur
quel point c'est 600 à simplement faire
ça
et on sentir donc dame 5 propose un
échange mais en fait on n'est pas obligé
on peut choisir on peut continuer notre
petit plan et après ça va les prendre
j'aime les B5 ah ouais non là c'est
super le pion simplement en force il y a
pas de question donc F3 est vraiment
très très intéressant ici
[Musique]
pour ton message juste pour te répondre
en fait c'est marrant parce que moi j'en
avais parlé avec avec
très très longtemps qu'en fait j'avais
pas les mêmes overlay si tu veux en fait
nous en France on n'a pas les mêmes
overlays que les autres pays et
bon nous les gens qui s'occupent de nos
overlay ils sont pas nombreux tu vois en
France alors que chez eux ils sont une
vingtaine peut-être même plus et en fait
on n'a pas les mêmes trucs donc là tu me
parles des des quatre boards je pense
que nous on l'a pas par exemple en fait
je sais qu'on a pas les mêmes on n'a pas
les mêmes les mêmes scènes sur Obs que
là
je sais pas moi je sais pas moi je l'ai
pas encore je l'ai pas encore installé
mais on l'a peut-être mais là tu vois il
faut déjà gérer les caméras si on doit
changer mais en fait même de manière
générale quand je je sais quand je quand
je fais des trucs quand je
[Musique]
donc
voilà voilà après c'est très bien
on a les chéquier
avec les Blancs
on joue pas même jeu moi je veux mater
alors certains veulent placer des pièces
donc je pense que c'est ici et du coup
ouais bon moi le premier coup qui m'est
venu à l'esprit c'était cavalé G5
l'ordinateur n'aime pas alors le premier
coup qui vient c'est ou alors un coup où
tu perds le pion là peut-être pour
reprendre d'abord
force de reprendre tu peux pas reprendre
de la dame parce qu'il faut protéger
puis on V6 jouer qui est une faute allez
on va on va regarder est-ce que c'était
fou franchement
alors le meilleur coup est ça
pour faire ça ça Dame des quatre et on
encaisse le pion de B6 c'était très bon
4 emprises du coup ça change tout
l'enfer il y a une poubelle
pour faire que c'est si un jour
technique des hacks là ça commence à
être à être très dur que quand tu es en
fait quand tu sais six bah faut prendre
puis on prend donc tu as un pion passé
avec les cases blanches la tour C1 le
fou les deux qui va défendre ses 6 à peu
très très vite être super dur en fait
même perdant à ce niveau là alors 28
secondes contre une 10
faut qu'il accélère même s'il est très
souvent
[Musique]
je pensais que tu parlais de ça après
j'ai pas du tout vu la partie plus
souvent
oui
j'ai pensé mais ça menace c'est pas
grand chose ouais j'ai pensé à ça j'ai
fait le proposer mais je l'ai pas en
avoir
soit à tous c'est sur twitch bah je sais
pas que je sais plus quoi ça s'appelle
mais cherche va sur le site TC partie va
sur le site et après ils ont une chaîne
twitch alors je sais plus comment elle
s'appelle la chaîne twitch
je peux chercher à poser
un peu le jeu peut-être ouais
surtout on calme le jeu surtout
encaisser le pion V6 en fait je peux pas
encore encaisser mais ça va pas tarder
je vais prendre et jouer qui est lycéens
ben je garde ma B6 je dis bah
démerde-toi moi je prendrai je veux
jouer avec si peu de temps
pour manger à 4
ouais je pense que c'était le coup et
oui c'est vrai que c'est un petit peu
15 secondes contre 8 ça va être très
chaud pour je sais pas
de fou est très forte il faut quand même
garder attention là pour c'est un pêche
caresser 4 Caval étrange cette qui
arrive à empêcher cette attention bon il
y a encore un petit échec je pense
d'abord mais ça doit être joué
évidemment ou tourner aussi bien pour
clouer menace
des tours sûrement
un peu trop safedia que je trouve parce
que maintenant c'est pas sûr que ça soit
gagnant
enfin je regarde
du coup il va jouer et il faut alors là
pour gagner ça vas-y bon courage très
compliqué
à 5 il veut pas faire
ils vont juste faire nul en fait
est-ce que tu penses que je peux ramener
le fou genre à 3 je marque
et j'ai 7 passer par derrière
pas sûr pas
ouais mais on risque tellement rien que
les blancs
il est foutu
assez rapidement devant mon protège
attention comme Opio A4
j'ai 5 et même pas du tout la jauge
il voulait faire faux si c'est avoir une
blockade en fait il a mal joué là
elle montrait ça aussi ce roi F4 est
et ça doit être nul bon bref
et on voit les coups jouer très vite par
les deux joueurs
est-ce que ça gagne ou pas le repasse
plus
le repasse plus et
nul à l'arrache de guerre
6 il fait foncé
[Musique]
ok je montrerai mon idée après pour
laquelle je pense que c'est perdant
c'est à mon avis il faut il faut faire
preuve cinq et aussi et ensuite 3 G6 et
E7 et tu prends le pion et tu fonces
mais il faut calculer aussi pour
calculer le pour calculer ça serait plus
simple pour bouger les pièces et nul
trois fois même position est-ce que
c'était gagnant ou pas ah mais c'est pas
comme ça tu vois
c'était ça mon idée de faire ça et de
faire ça mais en fait il fait dans le
temps
[Musique]
et 7 est fou G6 très très bien vu par
Monsieur stockfish bravo
avec cette seconde à la pendule c'est
introuvable je pense que malus qui peut
le trouver ça la preuve la preuve est-ce
que Robson qu'est-ce qui se passe chez
Robson on va essayer de mettre la cam
tout de suite contre daesh vanne
tout le temps
ces petites positions de maroczi
donc il va sacrifier une qualité pour
pour le CASE noir
et
voilà c'est incroyable ce jour indien là
franchement là on peut avoir des
partages en ce match
il s'en sortent bien je trouve les
California unicornes là
elle a fait nul produit
mais après
comme une terreur en rapide mais en fait
peut-être pas
écoute
[Musique]
elle a pas réussi à gagner
et elle a fait nul
[Musique]
elle laisse sur ton pétrole
en fait ok
donc sur le
ça fait 4,5
pour des hatchs livage qui fait un petit
un petit match pour l'instant tandis que
danache Var est énorme un ennemi contre
les deux meilleurs joueurs
écoute il est il est impressionnant pour
l'instant
et zéro pour cheval au va tandis que les
Américains sont plus solides globalement
plus un pour enfin un demi-sœur de pour
Maya et swarch et Robson un sur deux
victimes du joueur iranien et ça veut
dire fournisseur qui a une nulle donc
c'est pour ça en fait qui sont plus
compact pour l'instant
alors qu'est-ce que ça va donner en
terme de d'appareillement
ouais et ça veut dire quoi il sort
effectivement été en France ses parents
étaient
en France
donc voilà très connu
très connu des joueurs français est-ce
que qui alterne la couleur dis-moi
alors
du coup on va avoir
100% 100%
parce que c'est
donc
[Musique]
je te donne un par un on a suert contre
contre Bogdan et
on aura Robson contre livaich
on aura danetvar contre feuille d'or
et schubalova contre meilleur
c'est les quatre apparuments de la ronde
3 du coup
voilà
il vient d'avoir les Noirs effectivement
je te dis 100% mais en fait le dit
n'importe quoi parce que alors attends
qui double
évidemment c'est le premier que j'ai
bougé j'adore
je suis très très fan
c'est le premier que j'ai bougé non mais
là je rigole pas c'est très très sérieux
ok alors
déjà qui change d'aller noir
Sabina
que George meilleur écartent les noirs
chez les Blancs du coup donc qui ne
change pas dis-moi
chez les noirs qui ne changent pas
pas
ok et chez les Blancs
normalement il y a Robson qui ne change
pas d'accord
et on a
Robson donc
et on a Darius wirst change pas non plus
4 qui ne changent pas
tu es sûr
donc
les quatre qui ne changent pas c'est la
même équipe
j'avais pas remarqué ça en fait
c'est beau ça
il change de table mais a priori c'est
pas de couleur c'est la première fois
que je remarque en fait
deux trois
on va voir tout ça mais on s'attend à
moi je vois des départages dans ce match
je sais pas il m'a l'air fou ce match
c'est possible
c'est fort possible
qu'on ait droit et des partages
[Musique]
une partie par contre tu auras tout tout
qui va changer au niveau des couleurs
niveau de tout ça sur
la prochaine partie la carte tu veux
dire
pour l'instant
ok donc on voit les joueurs qui
s'installe là vous voyez à l'heure à
l'écran les noms sont fossés mais c'est
normal
ça va arriver très vite
de l'équipe mais écoute elle vient de se
faire quand même nulle avec les Noirs
contre un grand maître à quasiment 2600
Hello
[Musique]
excuse-moi
il aura les Noirs contre Robson
et ça sera la première partie peut-être
à commencer
donc on a ça
et
de joueurs
les noms sont pas les bons
c'est commandé par chaise.com
ok alors du coup
les parties qui vont commencer je pense
pour l'instant
pas encore pas encore lancé chez nous je
vérifie
non on n'a pas encore les appareils non
ça va arriver dans quelques instants ton
pour l'instant 4 points et demi à trois
et demi pour les Californiens unicornes
et match hyper hyper serré franchement
versé
facilement
disons que si DH avait converti sa
position gagnante contre Mayer voilà ça
ferait quatre partout donc ça joue
vraiment rien et après ces petits
détails qui font le
qui font l'écart
il peut se passer vraiment
tout et n'importe quoi dans ce match
n'hésitez pas si vous nous suivez sur
Youtube je sais qu'il y a certains qui
nous suivent sur Youtube
et elle elle aime bien envoyer donc
c'est une partie qui peut être sympa
donc on aura pour l'instant on n'a pas
encore vu la robinstein avec une
Française là
de Georges Meyer
n'hésitez pas à lâcher un pouce bleu si
vous êtes sur Youtube ou à vous abonner
à la chaîne comme ça vous ne ratez
aucune
des en tout cas des notifications des
retransmissions ensuite vous regardez ce
que vous voulez
et voilà c'est bien utile
aussi vous pouvez suivre sur les réseaux
sociaux évidemment je sais pas cheesecom
fr c'est sur Twitter ça c'est sûr sur
Facebook il y a des annonces aussi ou
pas
oui oui on a Facebook on a sur Facebook
on a à faire Instagram aussi
Instagram oui aussi d'accord super
donc je sais que sur Twitter ça c'est
sûr après sur Instagram non je suis pas
je suis vraiment
alors est-ce que ça je crois que ça a
repris en tout cas chez DH contre
Darius
search on va essayer de les avoir
à l'écran d'ici
donc du coup
très très peu contre Darius
qui est là
et ça va être un bon test pour Darius ah
non il est il a les blancs
tout à fait ah oui donc il est blanc
ça va mieux c'est compliqué avec les
Noirs contre contre DH parce que il joue
il joue très très bien
bon on est un gars je vous en parler
tout à l'heure cette position avec tous
les coups possibles sur ces 5 ce B4 se
foutent cette saucisse et un autre coup
qui est très très solide aussi c'est key
BD7
bon moins à la mode parce que moins fort
sans que les autres et donc moins moins
clarifiant dans le début mais tout aussi
bon
ou développement logique donc voilà faut
G5 et là on peut retomber facilement
voilà si X4 va être joué on peut
retomber facilement dans un Gambie de la
dame voilà fossette et là c'est quand
même c'est d'une solidité à toute
épreuve pour les Noirs surtout cette
ligne en plus
3 en fait 3 normalement avec les Blancs
il fait céder
en général ça donne vraiment rien ce
truc là pour les blancs on va voir
est-ce que
et ambitieux dans cette partie ou pas
je pense pas tu vois
c'est
comme ça ouais
on peut même aller peut-être échanger
les dames peut-être pas ce qui va faire
céder c'est pas sur B6 pouvait sept
ensuite il y a de quoi être son histoire
en plus bon ce sera pas la partie a
priori la plus marrante du de la ronde
donc
on a
live
Robson avec les Blancs
contre
livage le joueur croate
ok donc
il faut aussi
c'est standard tout à fait
décalage chaque partie
en tout cas qu'elle a pas joué au 4
parce que là c'est par contre son style
je pense à cette technique
la française avec des freins 4 ah oui
plutôt opté pour un pour ce mec D4
on va voir en tout cas ça va commencer
quelques instants sa partie
[Musique]
et on va voir apparaître
j'ai pas gagné en plus
c'est vrai que c'est un truc qui marche
souvent on garde cavalier
en fait bizarrement ouais bon c'est
quand même
mais il y a un petit peu de jeu quand
même encore
j'essaie d'oublier cette partie donc je
sais pas je sais pas comment
[Musique]
il travaille il y a des années de
pratique et des années de travail
madame des cinq petites finales
mais bon c'est vrai que ça lui ressemble
pas trop là pour le coup si tu m'avais
si je t'avais s'il y avait joué cette
partie en première partie disant tu
aurais pas été content
puis la petite finale elle a peur de fou
bon c'est pas c'est pas si évident après
il y a des positions qui sont bien
contre certains joueurs
quand on dit que tu as par exemple ici
elle c'est vraiment une petite attaque
donc souvent techniquement ce genre là
sera encore moins fort que les autres
dans notre domaine donc du coup
peut-être que je ne finale contre
une joueuse comme Souad c'est une bonne
idée pour les Noirs parce que la
position ici elle est peut-être un peu
pour les blanches à la part de fou bon
voilà mais après pour voir technique
et
donc voilà on va voir
[Musique]
je préfère au feeling je préfère vous
deux je suis d'accord
C4 et ensuite vous C3
même là
autour des 7 du coup et
et tour des 7 ça va être le coup en F6
je pense pas que ce que tu as envie de
faire ça
et là
je suppose va venir et c'est pas clair
n'hésitez pas à poser
non il y avait deux questions donc je
voulais répondre car ça ne joue dans
quelle équipe joue pour être l'équipe
canadienne des streamers canadiens et
Laurent tu fais encore des tournois
certainement moins que Stéphane je vais
jouer le mon prochain tournoi sera le
Top 16 je joue un petit peu en bout de
cigale en fait c'est pas des tournois
que je fais c'est des compétitions par
équipe ou des championnats de France ou
des trucs des tournois j'avais trop fait
des Open j'en ai trop fait j'en peux
plus des Open je peux plus jouer à open
j'arrive pas à me motiver mais des
compétitions par équipe et tout ça je
peux me
ça peut me plaire toi tu joues ou quoi
oui oui mais bon
j'ai beaucoup moins de temps et donc je
joue en équipe encore donc vous essayez
de remonter là ouais mais là j'ai pas eu
j'ai pas eu encore enfin j'ai fait un
weekend
en fait j'habite loin j'habite en
Espagne maintenant aux Canaries
et
du coup chaque fois pour venir c'est la
mais bon le niveau pas très très fort
quoi donc
tu joues pas tellement de d'Open en fait
ben je le rappelle que j'ai fait c'était
en septembre
dernier mais tu joues beaucoup tu sais
pour des gens comme moi tu joues
à l'époque faisait
voir deux parents
c'est toujours plus que toi mais en
terme de partie je suis pas sûr du coup
parce que moi j'ai tu vois l'année
dernière j'ai quand même joué champion
de France Olympiades Top 16 Bundesliga
donc finalement j'arrive à faire mes 30
40 parties
dans l'année au mine de rien avec ses
petits ses petits trucs par équipe ça ça
fait quand même pas mal de parties
peut-être cette année je joue un peu
moins mais je vais jouer le
jeu champion de France moi j'aime bien
la formule animation direct on gagne on
continue on perd on s'en va ça me va
très bien
oui
t'inquiète je joue une calice ici je
vais la streamer tiens la calife je vais
jouer une calife playing finalement j'ai
changé d'avis je la streamer ça motivé
parce que du coup je sais pas motivé
mais du coup de streamer c'est vrai que
ça peut être
ça peut être sympa je jouerai j'ai
regardé c'est le 13 mars je suis en plus
je stream
poussez trois cahiers des 5 et fous des
deux mais ouais effectivement
au moment où moi tous les deux donc
c'est quoi tonomax du coup j'ai entendu
que tu allais tout énorme de la vie mais
il te manque le vélo c'est ça c'est une
grande histoire ça
ma figure-toi que j'ai ca mandaté
tournoi là en septembre j'ai fait ma
cinquième norme de maître
donc voilà j'ai deux normes en pro et
mon hello max c'était 23 90
[Musique]
juste avant le confinement
et et a sorti le confinement j'avais
envie de jouer ça fait deux Anglais tu
as fait une partie que j'avais pas et du
coup j'ai tiens je vais faire deux open
ou 3 open d'affilée je fais trois open
d'affilée ouais et j'ai fait moins 110
voilà moins 110 -
20 en fait c'était ouf parce que je en
plus j'étais sérieux franchement je
voulais bien faire mais non en fait je
voyais rien cette tactiquement c'était
juste horrible parce que
j'avais
beaucoup de position très bonne pour toi
j'ai fait en Espagne on a joué la la
première division avec mon équipe et
j'ai fait un et demi sur 7 en gagnant
dans la partie qui servait à rien on ne
sortait en plus et dans toutes les
parties j'étais franchement il y avait
beaucoup de parties j'étais à plus 5 + 6
+ 7 et je perdais je perdais et en fait
je donnais toutes les pièces enfin je
donnais tout d'accord
là je suis à 23
je suis remonté non j'ai descendu à
22,80 quoi c'est genre
et là je suis parti en Argentine à ce
moment là après avoir perdu mes 100
points j'ai dit il faut que je change
les idées je suis parti pendant 5 mois
en Argentine
et à mon retour j'ai un petit peu joué
et puis là je suis remonté à 2300 alors
j'étais quand même à 84
dans les classements
mais j'ai perdu un 2000 bon tu sais
comme ça de toute façon et donc là je
dois être à 60 quelque chose 65 je sais
pas combien je sais pas mais là je sais
même pas d'ailleurs quand est-ce que je
vais rejouer parce que
j'ai j'ai rien vu
donc voilà donc c'est pas pour
aujourd'hui en tout cas d'accord bon bah
ça serait dommage de pas valider quand
même
ça commence à faire mais bon c'est
dommage 2016
mais bon
voilà quoi c'est pas c'est
du coup c'est pas des performances à
2450 comme les normes de mi c'est des
performances à 2600 et il faut avoir un
élo de 2500 voilà faut faire 3 c'est pas
ce même concept que ami à part que il y
a il y a 100 points l'autre plus où est
l'eau et 150 au niveau des normes donc
en vrai
c'est
plus souvent voilà quand tu pour devenir
amis c'est plus souvent ta situation
c'est à dire vous les joueurs font plein
de normes de amis mais n'ont pas le
hello est-ce que pour devenir GM c'est
plutôt l'inverse c'est-à-dire des gens
qui ont 2500 mais qui arrive pas à faire
les normes parce que du coup les normes
sont sont beaucoup plus élevés quoi il y
a beaucoup plus il y a un gros
différentiel donc les normes c'est très
difficile en fait généralement une norme
de Grand Maître ben généralement tu
gagnes un tournoi quoi c'est quasiment
ça quand tu es des gros tournois il faut
le gagner quoi ou alors vraiment faire
enfin c'est ouf parce qu'en plus la
moyenne des dos je crois que le minimum
je crois que c'est 23,80
la moyenneo la plus basse que tu peux
avoir et il y a plein de conditions en
plus il faut j'ai des étrangers il faut
jouer deux titrés les grands maîtres et
puis faire les points en même temps
c'est
ultra zone c'est plus
importantes des fois on a tous les
conditions mais tu lui communion
c'est ça tu peux jouer des étrangers la
moyenne et l'eau et tout ça c'est ça
c'est finalement c'est pas le plus dur
le plus dur c'est de c'est évidemment de
faire les non faut pas au moins battre
en 2600 ça c'est pas vrai
on peut battre d'ailleurs aucun grand
maître et de venir j'aime c'est rien à
voir il faut faire les points
en fait c'est un tournoi dans lesquels
il faut que tu
es une moyenne et donc 39 parties que tu
es une moyenne élo minimum 20 ou 80 et
que dans ce tournoi là tu es affronté au
moins 5 joueurs titrés dont trois trois
grands masse ça fait un championnat de
France sauf un peu de France
National
à l'époque
spéciale pour les championnat nationaux
où tu peux évidemment championnat
national on joue une seule nationalité
mais il y a quand même une option de
faire une lampe de grand-mère
nationaux ou tu as pas besoin de jouer
ce quota de joueurs étrangers c'est la
seule exception parce que moi j'ai fait
deux normes de mi en équipe en N1
et du coup j'avais dans une des normes
j'avais les joueurs j'avais étrangers
mais l'autre j'en avais aucun quoi et en
fait ça compte ça compte sauf si tu fais
trois normes
et que dans aucune des normes et ben tu
as les joueurs qui trait est allé
étrangers pardon et ben ça ça compte pas
mais maintenant ça a changé maintenant
il te il t'impose de faire au moins une
norme dans un open ou un truc comme ça
ça a changé je crois en 2023
ah d'accord récemment il faut absolument
que tu même tu as trois normes il faut
que tu aies une arme en européenne autre
que l'équipe
voilà donc voilà pour le les nouvelles
on va suivre un peu le match on a un peu
perdu le fil bon des se faire c'est très
solide chou valova la préférée répéter
les coups contre girls
contre un super rasoir et danesh va on
l'a pas encore vu il est très
impressionnant depuis le début il joue
contre sabinafo il sort normalement
c'est un chéquier où il devrait compter
sur un point
Sabina qui est ici que je vais vous
mettre tout de suite
à l'image
[Musique]
les normes de mi sont étrangers
maintenant
d'accord
seulement dans les compétitions par
équipe d'ailleurs j'avais un ami qui a
fait une norme enfin qui a fait une
norme pareil
dans de grands maîtres en National et ça
a pas été compté ils l'ont pas donné
parce que du coup la règle des des
étrangers qui ne comptent pas et bien
c'est que pour les Français
j'ai trouvé ça un petit peu dommage
depuis X années qui qui a joué en fin
qui a fait sa norme tu vois comme nous
mais sauf qu'il a pas les étrangers
comme nous
et on lui a dit ben en fait non toi
espagnol donc en fait ta norme elle
compte pas
tous les jours tout à fait quoi donc
c'est vraiment dommage quoi nombre de mi
bon enfin même
plus facile à faire qu'une arme de
grand-mère
pour moi
une très très grosse position on a le
fou qui va être en prise souvent il y a
peut-être du thème j'ai 4 x 5
pour l'instant mais je pensais peut-être
manger des cinq manger le 5 il va faire
4 mais malheureusement qui va défendre
le four
parce que tu veux dire que
bon enfin une qualité mais c'est pas
forcément ce que je voulais plus
typiquement dans ce genre de position
une qualité c'est pas assez on est
tellement bien dans tellement écrasant
avec ce centre de pions
on veut on veut plus que ça évidemment
d'ailleurs j'ai pas envie de changer de
fou moi je j'aurais plutôt un truc un
truc comme ça ouais fou un jouet
peut-être pour jouer un petit coup de H4
un petit coup de fou G3 elle va être
bonne moi je vous le dis
elle va être cher celle-là normalement
si il a l'air de savoir ce qu'il fait
hein Daniel va c'est pas pas rigolo non
mais franchement il a impressionnant
parce que au début il joue hyper bien et
non c'est une belle rue franchement
il doit être vraiment aux portes de
l'équipe parce que il a l'air de jouer
très sérieusement alors après il y a des
joueurs qui sont beaucoup plus forts
aussi
après 25 10 quand même il y a 17 ans il
a 17 ans simplement d'accord
on va tous cliquer tu sais
alors faut 3
il y a un jour il peut être la cible
d'un problème alors j'ai cinq choses pas
trop l'idée j'aime bien
en fait c'est tellement mal ok du coup
tu vas faire quoi tu vas manger
ouvrir les lignes ça donne du contre jeu
pas grand chose
[Musique]
si ça arrive il y a même des maths par
là qui arrive ou d'un monsieur
ok donc il y a eu ça ça
c'est pas mal aussi
on détruit tout là
ça reste encore pas si simple il faut
concrétiser
mais pour ça que le centre des blancs
est tellement énorme
c'est dur quand même niveau temps il a
quand même deux minutes à la pendule
pour 2 minutes 30
donc sur B4 sur B6 des noirs
comment est-ce qu'on va jouer ici est-ce
que tu reprends F4 c'est un coup ou pas
parce que quand même c'est vrai que
cette diagonale elle m'intéresse c'est
un coup on reste mieux certainement mais
bon c'est pas forcément
attention les yeux
en fait je crois que c'est complètement
fini
ça va faire
ça fait un point pour nos amis croates
et ça joue chez le reste mais bon
c'était mon pas très engageant
un point d'avance pour les Américains il
y a une égalisation
il reste deux parties je regarde mon
côté ce qui se passe
pas un match un 7 ah il restera deux
parties dans le 7 pardon dans le
ministre pardon pardon
tout à fait il restera que à la fin elle
sera quatre parties ça risque d'être six
partout
ils sont toujours en train de jouer
évidemment
[Musique]
j'ai pas compris alors ça c'est la
position
pourquoi
la partie
je vais tout revoir
pourquoi incroyable ce qui s'est passé
complètement foutu c'est ça ah ouais
donc on avait quitté là non mais il a
fait
il a pas fait
franchement c'est chaud
je sais pas ce qui s'est passé dans sa
tête ouais il a enlevé la caméra il est
parti fâché
et moi je me suis arrêté là et là il a
un dame quoi
il avait fait
c'est ouf hein il a dû
il a buggé parce que bien sûr quand il
fait cavalier B4 il a vu que son
cavalier prend les quatre il y a un dame
c'est pour ça qu'il a fait des bécasse
qui me surprend le plus
abandonner pas mais là on fait dame
mais bon
quand même tu fais un effort ouais mais
bon et donc là il y a un dame et au lieu
de faire un dame il a fait en cavalier
et et maintenant il a deux pions noirs
et ben je vois le 1-0 se mettre sur le
sur le sur le stream là tu vois il faut
absolument que
que schubalova en tout cas
non que comment il s'appelle danache va
l'emporte parce que là sinon les
carottes sont cuites
mais bon encore
donc ça c'est la partie de Daniel va on
l'a plus du tout là
pourquoi il se connecte
ce que j'ai fait ok c'est moi qui me
suis trompé pardon
et c'est chaud en fait
on a 7,5 du coup
elle est bouillante elle était pas mal
ça m'énerver dans la partie là était
bien revenu dans la partie
et donc on aura on aura donc DH qui va
jouer contre Robson
et on va voir livaich qui va jouer
contre schwarch on aura Daniel joueur le
MVP contre le très solide regarde Mayer
et
en comptant que je suis valova
bataille d'or c'est quand même une
joueuse clairement au dessus normalement
et bien ça fait plus qu'un point
rattraper sur trois échiquiers écoute ma
foi ça me semble très jouable
mais bon da qu'il est un petit T1
après bon quelqu'un professionnel face
une partie
tout encore possible faut qu'il arrive à
surmonter un peu son style
et peut-être essayer de battre Robson
alors les couleurs donc il y aura les
noirs
[Musique]
alors ça va faire du côté blanc
Robson ça va faire
là tu es en train de mettre dans mes
cheveux par qui a des Noirs
en dessous et bien cagoulé mais tu peux
le baisser il sera en bas
[Musique]
ça arrive mais là je pense qu'il a fait
ouais il a une hallucination
[Musique]
il a fait une super partie
quand même
de l'histoire là c'est moi qu'on puisse
dire donc il va jouer contre Ray Robson
ça sera une partie passionnante
il va vouloir se refaire Robson
donc
alors du coup da contre Robson après on
va avoir
un bon temps pour l'instant
il y a pas le droit de faire ça
revient du coup alors attends
les joueurs
donc
donc livaich
blanc
contre tiens
pas contents
à part les trois premiers deux trois
premiers c'est dans le reste ça
j'étais gagnant et j'ai raté des quatre
et il m'a flaguer et moi le premier
d'ailleurs je je
décris un truc que j'ai vécu et que j'ai
participé à la fête donc il va être il
joue contre
cherche si je suis bien c'est ça avec
les noirs
du coup
et pourquoi pas
ouais non c'est pas possible de
passer ouais on remarque tous les
explications sont bizarres de toute
façon
ce que je fais c'est que je clique sur
une pièce et après je mets la souris sur
la case et j'attends que tu joues pour
cliquer tu vois et là il a dit préparer
ça et que ben il a nerveusement cliqué
sur leur case pour valider le coup
contre notre ami Rania blanc contre les
cheval
et ensuite dans le duel par le duel des
joueurs
qui ont les blancs
aura les blancs très connu avec la
Grenoble alors je sais pas combien de
temps elle avait habité à Grenoble mais
je sais que c'est parents étaient à
Grenoble
[Musique]
voilà il manque je pense que Paulina
[Rires]
en fait ça va elle a fait son job
quatrième table et demi je pense ça va
parce que
[Musique]
se sentir mieux quand il faut focus
parce que c'est pas facile oui il a la
tête dans ses mains il fait un il fait
sur 3 alors qu'il aurait dû faire au vu
de ses parties lors de faire 3 sur 3 et
là il va me faire un très très gros
blender dans la partie qui aurait pu les
amener à 6 à 6 6 dans ce match et du
coup il va falloir qu'ils se reprennent
parce que
après
un blender de ce type là forcément
généralement tu as envie de te pendre
c'est ça mais bon c'est plié il nous dit
le tuture 50 ouais bah quasi d'accord
on sait jamais
ensuite tu as
livaïque ok il est pas forcément en
forme il est bon il a quand même les
blancs contre Darius bon c'est une
partie quoi et d'ailleurs qui fait pour
l'instant un super moment il est noir
contre meilleur il va pas prendre le
risque et normalement au 4 on a déjà un
cheval donc si jamais
gagné en fait
attention
en fait tout est possible encore une
fois c'est du rapide les joueurs sont
quand on sort mais mais bon 3 d'un côté
ou de l'autre c'est jamais vraiment
scandaleux je le vois possible
donc du coup les Américains tout à fait
au moins un et demi on va voir ce que
nous réserve DH mais bon en général il
est très solide donc il va il va jouer
dans son style technique actuel
en tout cas j'aime bien ce petit format
de ligue je trouve ça cool
ouais et puis ça va aller crescendo
forcément
voir des grosses équipes là qui vont se
jouer ça va être très très sympa
évidemment
alors est-ce que on voit léger décalage
envoyé les jours concentrés ils ont
certainement commencé à partir mais dans
quelques secondes on va voir des coups
qui vont s'afficher
tout ça pour
pour une petite
[Musique]
histoire
je pense que c'est
c'est juste que c'est ça se met en place
là
j'ai l'impression qu'il joue très vite
et tous deux un petit coup jouer par
des
à la place de Tours parce que tout
qui est la différence c'est que la tour
est pas en prise parfois c'est à dire
qu'on peut faire fu F4 et voilà si on
prend la
si on prend là si on a la tour en 2
c'est surtout huit on peut faire fu F4
on prend ici et on peut prendre du Fou
et le pion et pas et pas attaquer ici
voilà c'est la petite c'est le petit
écart par contre le problème c'est que
B6 me lave fois 6 et maintenant on doit
faire tout un mais d'un certain cas mais
si c'est pas terrible ça peut donner des
dames F3 en fait c'est des trucs des
petites finesses bon c'est un truc un
peu surprenant pour essayer de jouer
mais en général ça donne pas énormément
c'est un petit essai online pourquoi pas
de la part de DH ok ça avait été essayé
par Magnus carsonade contre Sergueï
kariakin en 2016
il avait d'ailleurs bon c'était égal
mais il avait fait gagner cette partie
il avait un gars je crois dans la finale
mais enfin il s'était fait le gain par
lui-même c'était pas c'est pas du tout
l'ouverture c'était je pousse pendant
des heures 4K F5 je me rappelle cavalier
4 était vraiment à l'époque en tout cas
était pas mal ici mais bon Caval F5 doit
pas être très mauvais C3 et c'est vrai
que ça va ça va pour les Noirs mais ça
va aussi pour les blancs léger plus
allez ça va être intéressant de voir ça
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres parties qui
ont commencé
alors l'autre partie qu'on commence
oui tout a commencé sauf la dernière
qu'on va attendre d'ailleurs avec un
patience donc tout a commencé hein
je pense que c'est une heure
OK et on va voir exactement
on joue donc on va montrer cette
berlinoise celle-là si vous suivez les
tournois online vous la connaissez et
hop et là ça c'est la fameuse
la femme ça
fait nul enfin ça fait nul
[Musique]
mesdames des trois dames des 7 et un
coup qui paraît peut-être pas très
logique mais en fait ça protège ici ça
peut jouer aussi sur casse blanche
attention il manque un fou de caisse
blanche pour le pour les blancs donc
c'est toujours c'est toujours
intéressant et donc c'est vraiment c'est
le coup qui est considéré comme le
meilleur ici Dame des 7 donc aucune
surprise faut 3 et à 5
menace aussi fois 6 ouais prépare
prépare des choses ici en général on
fait des coups comme d'hab C3 pour
justement plus être dans fois si c'est
éventuellement les blancs s'ils arrivent
à faire à mettre un quelque chose à
bloquer sur case noir ils vont être très
bien tandis que les Noirs vont essayer
d'empêcher ça c'est toujours à double
tranchant ce genre de ce genre de
position
de savoir ce qui fait quand même ce
problème de dame C3 ici c'est qu'il a
fou B 4
donc on peut pas faire ce qui est
ce qu'on a envie de faire et donc
tourner un
je crois que c'est MG4 le coup ici
on t'entend plus attends désolé
il y a un objet 4 parce qu'en fait tu
empêche d'un de ces trois aussi parce
qu'il y a tout en prise et tu menaces
ou G6
les fossettes à l'air très raisonnable
aussi
et peut-être possible maintenant mais
bon tu me diras peut-être pour perdre un
temps on perd un temps mais bon bizarre
on verra on va faire un petit tour des
stades
et la prochaine c'est donc les deux
hommes en forme et regardez moi ça Mayer
ça ne rigole pas bon voilà ça c'est la
fameuse avec
toutes les pièces échangées
symétrique ça va faire nul c'est
vraiment un truc pour faire nul
alors est-ce qu'ils veulent la jouer un
tout petit peu
je crois même que
il veut prendre et là une petite main tu
reprends il faut prendre un 7
on n'a jamais complètement envie de
faire ça parce qu'on donne la colonne
voilà alors ça reste ben voilà ça ce
genre de final ça peut être très
désagréable pour les noirs
parce qu'on va on va venir là ça peut
être évident et pour ce 7
continuons la symétrie alors surtout
reprend on reprend père un pion mais pas
pour longtemps ton avis de te reprendre
à deux et c'est nul
donc fousser 5 fousser 4 OK
bon a priori nul on est d'accord
après cette nuit là enfin voilà quoi en
plus c'est nul avec les Noirs contre
celui qui est dans l'équipe en face
quasiment le plus en forme je crois
qu'il a deux sur trois très dur à battre
c'est pas il y a pas de quoi se prendre
des risques inconsidérés
on va aller voir Paulina schubalova
contre Sabina four et sort
et ça joue à fond un peu chaud voilà qui
garde une position
bien très compliqué
alors la jauge qui aime pas du tout ce
coup là
OK
pourquoi c'est pas clair
biroute 212 qui demande pourquoi la
France joue-t-elle un PCL oui une équipe
française et équipe blitz de la chaîne
Blitz stream avec
Sacha
mais le Boyer dès maintenant
il y a encore il y a encore Katia lagno
Étienne Macron
et il faut prendre à trois qui manque de
ça manque de ça manque de peps tout ça
pour les blancs il faut quand on fait
vous voyez quand on quand on dit a c'est
très bien F4 et actuel est fou braquer
mais en gros sur fois 6 on peut pas
jouer il faut prendre
soit on ouvre la grande diagonale en
fait un truc qui est G4 soit on fait ces
quatre pour garder les fous et essayer
de monter une attaque mais on peut pas
faire voilà là ça a pas de du coup le
plan est bancal c'est à dire qu'on joue
un coup un coup agressif un coup passif
ça ça peut pas ça peut pas aller il faut
tant pis quand on quand on y va il faut
pas il faut pas reculer
et pour C8 oursins vous voyez maintenant
c'est très facile à jouer pour
énormément on peut imaginer d'un musette
gagnant encore un tempo tu dois protéger
ton pion tu sais pas je sais pas c'est
pas très agréable
je m'attends une victoire de cheval au
vin parce que tu en penses je suis
d'accord
on va voir la partie de la partie deck
c'est peut-être pas la plus marrante
mais bon on va voir si desa qu'est-ce
qui peut pousser ou pas paire de fou
[Musique]
contre Ray Robson
paire de fou pas pour longtemps non si
je prends
académique dans un verre pas mal pour
les blancs tiens il a 8,54 il est en
tilt mais il met bien la pression
parce que le problème si tu joues au
foot que reposer c'est ce qui va c'est
ce qu'il va faire c'est que je vais
mettre un foulard tu vas jamais
récupérer la colonne aller à moi cette
couleur
mais je vais faire simplement ou
peut-être même
pour faire tout un je garde ma dame en
F4 qui est pas mal placé quand même qui
est bon
ouverte quand on a une tour là il y a
une seule cloneur sur l'échiquier donc
c'est la colonne E il faut la prendre
avec nos tours et en fait elle va se
fout en B5 et ben il fait un gros job
parce que il couvre la case de 8 c'est
la grande case de la tour ou de la Dame
des noirs pour rentrer sur la colonne et
du coup allez voir pour plus jamais
contester donc pour l'instant on va
faire roi et fin au terme des deux pour
le tour 1 je vais occupé la colonne E et
puis je peux grinder un petit peu dans
la position avec ça pendant que toi ben
tu as tu as pas grand chose à faire
d'ailleurs bah si je suis roi F1 tu
reviens tant que tu fais rien bah je
peux presque gagner la dame quoi donc
quand même un manque d'espace aussi avec
les Noirs
opposé il y a pas vraiment de faiblesse
chez les noirs
donc on va ça reste solide mais
solide mais c'est un moyen très simple
quoi ah ouais ouais plus qu'un peu je
pense honnêtement et regardez le temps
cette 40 contre 3,20 donc ça ça sent bon
pour les pour les chats bouledogs
on va voir qu'est-ce qu'il a fait des
hack il a fait roi F1 comment le comment
le présentait pour faire tout un il joue
toujours très vite intéressant ce match
alors est-ce que le salut viendrait pas
attention pour les Américains là et il
faudrait que
finalement je cherche chez leur et leur
presque leur meilleur espoir
en fait
ça change rien dans le fait que je vais
gagner la colonne et que tu pourras plus
bouger quoi
même mais c'est une option aussi
je mets un tour en vain et puis je
montais mon roi pousser les pions
beaucoup moins d'espace quoi alors ici
ça c'est un peu éclairci il y a la paire
de fou pour les Noirs mais il y a un
pion plus ou moins faible des pièces
quand même assez actives
et donc c'est chaud
c'est chaud c'est chaud c'est à peu près
équilibré je trouve je sais pas au
feeling
je sais pas qui est mieux
je pense que d'abord peut être pas mal
si ça arrive à
activer la leur fou quoi en fait
c'est typique des
pions isolés quand un pion en isolé
généralement tu dois jouer actif avec
tes pièces t'inquiète pas à jouer actif
et bien ce pion de tomber ça à la longue
ça peut être problématique après il y a
aussi de quoi se refaire par là il y a
des faiblesses pour les blancs
c'est pour ça que ça me fait dire que
c'est un peu
d'ailleurs peut-être la suite logique ça
serait peut-être de simplement de
répéter alors ça fait pas les affaires
des
des Croates quoi que quoi que quoi que
bon ouais il faut voir ce qui se passe
en fait parce que
il marque au 1 et 4
[Musique]
on va voir on va laisser tranquille et
voir ce qui se passe peut-être voilà ça
se qu'est-ce qu'on regarde je suis
valova ou des hatchs
et après on tournera d'accord
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il y avait
dame
noirs sont pas moins bien ça c'est sûr
plutôt mieux certainement
[Musique]
tout à fait
et en l'air comme on dit
comment on fait on peut jouer
j'aime bien que c'est comme ça sur
4 petits coins intermédiaire
et si je prends pas l'idée de venir en
BK
je viens de défendre depuis
tu te défends comment
c'est quand même dommage on n'a pas
envie
de partout non c'est pas terrible hein
gentiment
oui sur le papier ça a l'air sympa mais
effectivement dans la vraie vie c'est
pas si évident on n'a pas trop de coups
harmonieux là et même tu vois juste le
cavalier français 6 ben en fait ça fait
pas forcément plus à faire des blancs
parce que ben il reste un cavalier un
peu passif le cavalier qui défend B3
c'est 4 et puis qui défend aussi de la
classe de 4 donc quand même la casse de
cavaliers donc en fait les noirs sont
vraiment hyperactif
pressant sur C4 et ça va être en plus
qui traîne parfois dans des cas où on
prend ici on peut pas trop reprendre du
pion parce qu'elle a le pion enfin bon
bref
j'aime bien tiens parce que comme ça ça
va être une bonne solution pour pour
protéger son pion des mais bon elle a
plus que 3 30 aussi 30 donc c'est chaud
peut-être
un peu vicieux mais
[Musique]
je veux le manger 4
ok
pas sûr que ça gagne du matériel mais
quand même ça c'est pas un truc ah si ça
gagne du matériel en plus qu'à la fin il
y a la fourchette ça ne va pas
cette case aux quatre qui est faible
pour toujours parce que les pions ont
trois avancé là ce F4 dans l'ouverture
pour attaquer et bien on a envie
maintenant de jouer F4 F2 tout
simplement c'est clair ou de l'or que
d'une case déjà mais ce cavalier F5
cette manoeuvre cavalier F5 D6 E4 hyper
intéressant pour revenir se mettre au
cavalier sur la belle case là
qui sera un délogeable en E4 au
contraire c'est ça pour ça alors vous
avez peut-être quelques viewers vont
nous dire et mais il y a le cavalier 5
mais celui-là on peut l'enlever quand on
veut enfin quand on veut quand on pourra
mais enfin en tout cas dans le au bout
du bout on pourra toujours on pourra
toujours l'enlever et tout chaud 76 qui
nous dit qu'on est beau
moi j'ai jamais eu de doute sur ça
mais
j'ai jamais douté voilà peut-être ça va
venir je sais pas voilà les années ça
n'est pas ça
alors c'est 5 joué par Sabina fasor
qui
écoute c'est compréhensible ça
inexpugnable tout à fait en rouge merci
Baron Rouge c'était le mot que j'avais
le seul bout de la langue mais parfois
on trouve on trouve plus et moi
alors
c'est 5
c'est compréhensible mais on sent que ça
peut être très bon parce que on va être
tout seul si on pouvait si tu me dis GB4
B5 C6 ok mais là
après la position elle est quand même
difficile donc c'est sa réaction elle
est clairement compréhensible au vu de
la situation il y a plein de faiblesses
quand même mais tu sens que c'est un
château de cartes qu'il a qui va
commencer un peu à
s'écrouler leur prise prise comment tu
joues derrière
je sais pas là parce que tu as peut-être
C6 mais un coup comme un 5
on est sûr on peut tout ça qui a jamais
bécate et on va s'occuper gentiment
du collègue en C5 et il me semble qu'on
est quand même pas mal
de toute façon sa structure elle est
dégueulasse
à 4 b3c5 c'est ça va pas
ça c'est clair
mais d'ailleurs
qu'il faut pas précipiter tu vois dans
ces situations là on va l'avantage on a
la meilleure pièce et du coup à 5 tu
fixes avant même de passer à l'action et
de jouer en cavalier ses six ou essayer
de faire un truc je trouve ça bien ouais
mais en l'occurrence c'est pas sûr que
ça soit beaucoup mais bon ok c'est qui
donne les idées en tout cas
prendre son temps tu vois c'est bien
parce que c'est vrai que bon à cinq
c'est un coup un peu
je sais pas comment le dire mais un coup
un petit peu
c'est un coup silencieux
alors
mais elle réfléchit c'est quoi je crois
c'est une bonne c'est un bon moment pour
réfléchir à la bien raison Polina parce
que c'est pas un moment évident est-ce
que déjà est-ce qu'il faut prendre
forcément c'est pas sûr qu'il fallait
prendre parce que finalement qu'est-ce
que tu menaces avec les Blancs
je suis pas sûr
[Musique]
apparemment ah ça fait nul mince alors
il a pas réussi à mettre la pression
notre ami idéal
2 minutes
d'accord très très bien joué très bien
défendu de la part de Robson sauna faut
avouer que
très important
du coup pour pour les Croates et
maintenant il faut il y a victoire
qu'est-ce qu'il fait genre et gargmeyer
toujours en train de jouer cette
position
et il joue la gagne
il faut toujours faire attention aux
gens de finale livage qui qui
est pas loin aussi de perdant hein
pour les amis
si Georges Meyer
hyper page je pense que c'est terminé
parce que les vaches
d'être
d'avoir une belle position pour pour
visser quand pour terminer dans je sais
pas comment ça se termine ça
attends
de tourner ah bah plutôt un bon coup
mais NAS B4 B5 maintenant
ça tourne au vinaigre pour nos amis
accroître mais là c'est vrai que des
Hatch les amis dedans
c'est mal cette dernière ronde avec ce
terrible alors je sais pas PRIMOVE gaffe
appelez-le comme vous voulez mais
en tout cas déjà juste la partie même
juste avant
ils auraient mené avant le
avant le dernier set si si des Hatch
avait tout quand même après il a trois
sur trois tu vois enfin je viens il
aurait dû avoir trois sur trois mais
d'un autre côté bon ah c'est le buteur
quand même donc il faut qu'il c'est le
buteur mais le numéro 1 faut pas non
plus tout le temps tu as là on voit les
lives il a fait un sur quatre
donc en fait
donc là il reste deux parties
c'est que en fait là le problème des
Noirs c'est que il faut absolument qu'il
gagne
et là s'il faut refuser la nul avec ton
B3 tu vois
si forfaits
bon sont priori perdant mais si en plus
les blancs vont même pas gagner je te
raconte même pas non c'est fini on va
rester sur le chevalova qui va nous qui
a joué pour le fun cette dernière partie
a priori cavalier 5 puis on prend C5
elle a gagné un pion schubalova ah bah
elle va elle va gagner ce qui a donné
des regrets quand même à cette équipe
croate encore plus ça va ça va faire 7
ou 7 et demi et voilà en contrat les
points de DH malheureusement
devrait proposer nul
franchement bah après je pense qu'il
voit le score en direct
on va dire
normalement mais bon il y a tellement
pas de risque
non il y a pas de
franchement regardez il va il est en
train de il est en train de prendre des
pions là il va prendre ici il va dès
qu'on va pousser il va suivre avec le
roi et bonne chance bon c'est un
perdable
c'est impermé de chez internet
en fait c'est vrai exactement là
elle a complètement craqué sa vie d'un
foyer
c'est deux pions
ça marche pas du tout il y a rien
absolument rien c'est ça le problème il
y a rien du tout
je peux envoyer un petit truc par là un
petit truc à 6 et Terminator
pour un miracle allez on met on met la
caméra dessus
depuis le début tu as vu le espagnol
il reste 30 secondes
à moi aussi une déco allez la déco
je le vois pas ne pas gagner ça c'est
justement possible
[Musique]
les Américains
pour gagner le match il faut que daniège
voir gagne sa partie avec les Noirs mais
là vous imaginez la position c'est quoi
ton foutu
on a vu d'autres une déco ça serait pas
la première
H3 bon moi j'ai 3 du coup
j'ai trois jouets roi B6 et tour C8
qui fait ça de manière très pro
malheureusement
mais je trouve que c'est pas moi je vais
proposer à sa place mais bon
parce qu'honnêtement
ça va terminer tour de roi F3
Tourer 1 et là c'est en question
terminée
pas en attendant une déco ou mouse flip
en tout cas un petit tour à champ qui
traîne pour les noirs
[Musique]
bravo à cette équipe
California unicornes des États-Unis pour
ce super match et
sur papier
mais c'est vrai que moi je pense que je
leur ai donné favoris les États-Unis
depuis le début parce qu'en fait
je suis d'accord mais on savait pas que
la neige va était aussi bon ta neige va
quand même
surpris des hatchs on le voyait enfin je
le voyais en tout cas faire plus de
points genre un petit un petit 3 et
livaich transparent vraiment
et après les autres ils ont fait plus ou
moins leur match en Polina je pense que
c'est presque standard son score même si
on va faire un peu mieux
mais c'est pas non plus c'est pas non
plus incroyable mais en fait en face tu
as trois bombs de ça
d'ailleurs c'est trois monstres
tous les points
en dessous clairement il a fait gagner
quand même une partie mais c'était
contre livaich je crois donc bon
prestation
difficile donc on rappelle je crois que
c'est la semaine prochaine le la suite
la suite de la procès League Stéphane ou
pas oui alors j'ai j'ai
on en parlera mais
on va voir
stream la suite la semaine prochaine
mais je crois que on va ils vont nous
choisir les matchs pas forcément tout
stream chez j'ai bien compris mais je
sais pas encore on va voir en tout cas
merci à tous d'avoir suivi de stream
merci beaucoup merci à toi Laurent de
m'avoir invité
et puis et puis écoute ben à la
prochaine pour pour la suite de
l'événement
et à bientôt à bientôt à tous ciao ciao
bonne soirée
[Musique]